Redemption
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
bites out can't you hear the thing when
your lights off can't talk heavy with a
light job my win might lose or I might
draw
haters
but it comes out if you really want it
in the ring I don't send a contract out
knock his contacts out
ain't no competition in the ring of
sight because I'm spitting phenomenal
swinging fire talking pickled peppers
making Peter Piper cause I might go live
like rude discussion and deflate your
chest like a food reduction you be
talking like you wanna do conscious and
I do the custom attitude adjustment
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that I deserve for another
knuckle sandwich
even got his one and only homie Kevin
you a phony homie now you owe me action
happens thinking Tony Toni Toni Braxton
and they all want to talk for attention
but the fame only lasts for an incident
mama got hands throwing bread for the
pension imma leave them red you can
dance to Redemption
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
might lose
[Music]
if you really want it in the ring God
don't send the contract off knock his
contacts out you will feel mice trying
to take a life but ain't no competition
in the ring of sight because I'm
spitting phenomenal swinging fire
talking pickled peppers make them pay
the piper cause I might go live like a
rude discussion and deflate your chest
like a food reduction you
do concussions in a dude a custom
attitude adjustments these are fighting
words better give me that respect that I
deserve for another knuckle sandwich I
would serve having sipping moving like a
tiger swerve out here acting bad thank
you Michael Jackson even got his winning
only homie Kevin you a phony homie now
you owe me action have em thinking Tony
Toni Toni Braxton and they all want to
talk for attention but the fame only
lasts for an instant mama got handsome
and bread for the pension imma leave
them red you can dance in Redemption
[Music]
foreign
those are some of my favorite Knockouts
welcome to another combat talk
professional fan
the king what's going on people
so a lot of people's been asking me to
do uh these entertainment fights right
so I'm definitely gonna do this
entertainment fight because
I want to see uh Jake Paul get knocked
out
so I'm looking for Anderson Silva to
step up and do his thing but uh
as we step into the room let's wipe our
feet and let's uh hit that like let's
hit that subscribe and let's uh share
that out
what you sipping on what just sipping on
today um
a little weird concoction
I wanted some apple juice and
I definitely wanted a little bit of
energy drink a little bit of Pep me up
so
um a little bit of energy drink a little
bit of Red Bull
um
Tito's
and some apple juice
tastes good tastes okay I said now if I
mess up the drink for the night that's
the drink for the evening so
but I'm definitely pepped up right now
we have a hull versus Bell and this is
the worst that I've seen like Uriah
Hall's body look uh but he's giving uh
Le'Veon Bell all types of hell and um
shout out to Le'Veon Bell for even
putting on some gloves let's see what we
got going on here
that's going on Dragonheart yoby that's
my dude yes yes yes IMAX was good
screenshot Jay what's going on baby
uh Isaac what's good what's going on
casual nerd oh my my boy first of all
casual nerve problems that is my dude uh
statue collecting is our passion uh if
you haven't went to his channel to
subscribe please at some point in time
go watch his stuff it's great stuff uh
me and him interacted with each other
without even knowing that we did because
he purchased some uh statue from me I
think it was Wonder Woman or something
like that put that in the chat casual
um I think it was Wonder Woman and uh
it's always great to be able to share
your passion with somebody else and and
for somebody to get some some a statue
from you or a collectible from you that
you actually love so much so it does it
was really dope and um he's a real good
dude in the community fantastic stuff
that he's doing there on his channel so
if anybody gets a chance go and
subscribe to Casual nerd problem um
problems it's so fun let me see what's
going on Carolina what's good what's
going on Sith Lord that's my dude uh
Isaac shout out to Cog mixing that
advanced GG blood orange and with the
honey that's what's up
yeah it was Wonder Woman right she's
right behind you that's what's up yeah
yeah
um I sold uh my Wolverine and my
Sabretooth I had uh some uh OG Wolverine
OG Sabretooth and I was so happy that
the dude got him and brought him a pair
because it was uh one of my first pair
of uh statues that I did get but you
know making space getting rid of
Sideshow stuff got a couple other stuff
that's you know ready still like that
Wolverine but uh other than that right
now we are in round four of the hug fest
with Le'Veon Bell and Uriah Hall I
thought Uriah Hall would go out and
knock this dude out but again this is
entertainment stuff so
we have to take that with a grain of
salt hopefully the main event uh shines
and we get to see Jake you know because
Jake goes out there he swings those
hands and um
or we could see Anderson Silva you know
do his thing but uh right now is is
you know I don't like to call the
undercards uh be honest with you I was
very interested in this undercard I
didn't know if I was going to go back
and forth to the lumachenko fight
because remember lomachenko fights
tonight uh and I did want to see what he
was going to do
against a young bull but um hopefully
hopefully
my wife texted me they need to hit that
like button we got 31 in here we got 19
likes let's let's get those likes up
let's share that out let's get that to
everybody
um and then we're gonna start getting
our conversation going on who we think
gonna win tonight or who we want to win
tonight
you already know who I want to win
tonight uh let's stop this uh Jake Paul
but you got people out there riding for
Jake Paul baby
this is crazy but this this is
this right here is horrible
entertainment with Uriah and Le'Veon
Bell Le'Veon Bell is dipping at the
waist hugging on Uriah Hall and looks
tired looks out of shape I believe we
had him on the Jets for a period of time
uh thank God he's off our team right now
so we can try to win let me see what we
got going on right there assalamualaikum
my brother what's going on hard to find
that's my brother peace be with you
brother
uh no thought on you would have uh
alaikum salaam my brother
uh I thought of you would have one with
the lomacheco Ortiz fight
um nah uh let me tell you something
you guys uh asked me to do this
right the uh entertainment fights and I
don't really cover them
because they're just you know pure
entertainment for me oh they go Chris
cyborg she doesn't even look like
herself anymore oh my God that's kind of
weird uh so today's uh fight is
dedicated to you guys like the
entertainment aspect of it uh to you
know to see Anderson Silva and uh Jake
Paul get into the ring into my respect
for Anderson Silva uh wanted me to do
this I really wanted to do this man so
who else we got in here Verge Brazil
what's good baby Sinister they're paying
for them wins I hope Paul gets folded
oh uh uh dragon heart you want my origin
story about boxing
um uh I gotta I gotta respect
um
the the the
[Music]
great Puerto Rican sensation
um
and
it's it's it's very is it's very
different like how I I got into boxing
because uh growing up in a single family
household uh in the projects you know
only boy at the time
uh before my mother had my sister and
only boy period And You Know You Gotta
Fight You Gotta Fight and sometimes you
know I wasn't about that especially at
my age I'm and my son's uh can attest to
this they can say that they are a
certain age but they look older right so
I'm like 11 years old looking like I'm
15 16 years old so of course the 15 16
year old kids want to uh fight me
so
it's uh it's uh projects that's down the
hill and we're playing down there and
you know I got into a couple of scraps
and my mom's got sick and tired of me
coming upstairs with tears in my eyes
you know
so all right uh there's a project that's
called Maria Lopez down the hill from
where I live and I'm down there and I'm
playing around and I see a car pulling
the car pulls in and it's a red Ferrari
I've never seen no Ferrari in my life
I'm broke as a joke right uh we we have
uh we eat and spam you know
and um Hector Camacho comes out and I
didn't know that was Hector Camacho at
the time I didn't know who he was and uh
he he goes hey hey little man watch my
car for me
and um he stands in front of his I stand
in front of his car and I have my arm
folded don't nobody touch his car you
know uh type of thing and uh he came out
and I think he gave me like 50 bucks and
told me if I meet him at the boxing gym
um up the hill he'll give me another 50
bucks well actually Trinidad is my
cousin a casual nerd that's that's a
totally another thing I found out that
he was a family uh because my
grandmother's Puerto Rican her maiden
name is Figueroa his family name is
Figueroa and it's it's a whole big thing
but anyway
he takes he he drives up the hill and I
take off running behind him and um
get up there
and get down to the gym the gym is Fort
Apache on Third Avenue in the Bronx it's
no longer there but um
and that's where I fought out of and and
I get down there when I get there uh
he's there and he goes oh you made it
little man man I think he gave me
another 50 or 20 I I don't remember
really I think it was fifty dollars and
so I guess I had a hundred dollars and I
used that money
to pay for my boxing and when I'm
talking about seeing poetry and motion
Hector Camacho was
uh
this you see we see deities we we read
about deities we read about you know
Hercules and all this stuff and I'm
pretty sure that people saw these guys
with these Feats they were doing these
immense Feats in the world and was like
oh my God you know these people got to
be Gods well I'm talking about I seen
him hitting the speed back he was
already in his clothing when I got to
his shorts and stuff I saw him jumping
rope
I saw him hitting the speed bag
I don't think he did any heavy bag that
day
and he was getting warmed up because he
was going to spar
and I after seeing Hector Camacho do
that like in person
it was the greatest living thing that I
thought I saw at that time right and and
I wanted to be a part of that and you
know thank God for him
showing me that I mean I lived and I
breathed the boxing gym I stayed dinner
I did a whole bunch of stuff there and
you know the highlight of my amateur
career was I was uh going to be
sponsored by Shabazz on
116th Street in Harlem and Muhammad Ali
God Rest his soul um came to Shabazz and
they owned a whole bunch of stuff
they're like schools barber shops
because I would go to the barber there
and they were like yo um my barber
called me was like yo come here because
it was going to spawn to me I was
supposed to go to Terry Norris and Arlen
Norris boxing in uh Texas
and I didn't go story for another day
and I go in there and when I go in there
like they have the foi out in the front
and then like you know let people in and
they like look let them in let them in
and I'm coming inside and they go that's
the kid I was telling you about
I'm like what
and it's like you have a scene like
somebody has an aura like a glow
I don't know maybe I'm bugging but he
looked like he had an aura he had a glow
to me
Muhammad Ali look like and I'm just like
my single greatest moment I know a lot
of dudes friends when I ran Barclay
friends with Mitch Green
um friends with Superman Aaron Davis me
and Aaron Davis is really cool shout out
to Pennell Whitaker uh rest in peace uh
good friends with him
but to see Muhammad Ali in the flesh is
it's absolutely it was he had a glow
around him if you can see somebody's
Aura he had a glow around him so I've
been very privileged to be around know a
lot of people and exchange conversations
with boxes and in the boxing Community
um so yeah that eagle dragon heart
that's that's my joint right there let
me see
potted meat with Ritz crackers there we
go see see me me and Sinister grew up
together so citizen knows
um how broke we were you know we we were
broke we were really broke but we made
it happen and and um we here Sinister
we're here
problem Hector was so fresh and
explosive yes
felt like that way when I saw my Jiu
Jitsu for the first time that's right
what's going on seek a great Xbox
International gang what's going on I'm
chilling
yo you got to see it all live in person
yeah
I got to see him in person
um before he before he passed
nut stuff like it's like some things in
my life like I'm just like I wouldn't
have traded my life for nobody else's
life it's the stuff that I got a chance
to see the people I got a chance to meet
you know be around certain things
certain key things in my history or
history that uh affected my generation I
was there and in in that mix and it's
absolutely crazy all right so we have
Jake Paul right now riding a horse in to
the stadium
I got to give this guy respect
he's a showman showman he knows how to
sell Jake Paul is a little bit different
um okay oh so this this okay so this was
when he was going to his open air
workout so they do open air workouts and
Anderson Silva did his open-air workout
that's where everybody is there to get a
chance to see them working out see them
working on different things I gotta
respect both brothers because both
brothers
um dedicated themselves to the sport and
dedicated themselves to trying to learn
their craft and I gotta respect them for
that man you got to put it in the ground
you can't fake it you don't you don't
play boxing
you do boxing and some dudes probably
don't respect the fact that he wasn't
um this wasn't what he actually did for
a living but uh this is what he's doing
now right you're not a box until you
start boxing right he won his fights
right so I don't care if he paid for him
or not
um
I don't know man this is this is this is
a true step of fight for him Anderson
Silva Anderson is no joke let me see
he's still working hard trying to be my
come up like you I'm 30 so it's late
listen listen
you're never too late for anything
every day you you take breath every day
you breathe it's never too late for
anything you just don't give up you just
got to keep going I know sometimes you
get very very hard but you just put your
head down and you just keep going do
what you got to do sometimes it beeps on
you man trust me I've been through a lot
of stuff and I'm you know go through
stuff now but again
don't don't give up
if you ever need to talk you already
know when my Twitter line is all day
I hope Anderson Silva wins I hate how
these Legends are killing and Legacies
[Laughter]
really he's riding horses yeah Jake is
good if Jake wins again boxing is my
favorite then the MMA I think I'm gonna
be a good fight quick hail
Marvel wasn't a thing until Stan hit 40.
that's right
okay so we have something weird this
happened
here let me see
what's going on tell me if anybody
watching the fight did you get a weird
thing
that just popped up
let me see
how to reset my videos
I hate Showtime
uh streaming I really do
okay
[Music]
let me see
because Showtime streaming app is really
ridiculous
all right so
let me see the MMA have MMA
anybody tell me if you're watching it
and your stream just stuttered because
my stream just started I'm trying to
log out and log back in
to it
Bluetooth
that's right I don't think there will be
a cable but I'm pulling for silver yeah
let me see
because right now we have um
top rank Okay so
my fox card top rank is working
let's see
this is Goofy stuff right here hey goofy
stuff
there we go okay just had to log out and
log back in So Jake Paul's walking in I
love The Duality what he's doing he's
using the black and white thing and
that's really cool
um that pays homage to a lot of uh stuff
if you into a secret knowledge and stuff
like that so I'm pretty sure that these
dudes uh study meditate and um he he's
actually based out of Puerto Rico which
is really crazy
let that sink in a little bit right Jake
Paul and his brothers based out of
Puerto Rico they live out of Puerto Rico
it's really dope stuff
Sylvia my favorite MMA fighter of all
time what's the point of a dude fighting
agent non-boxes
yeah yeah
um it should be starting uh probably
within the hour usually we wrap up by 12
o'clock you know the latest to be honest
with you
um remember Anderson Silva fought um
was Julio Cesar Chavez Jr
you know and he beat him up excuse me
pretty good so
MMA remember Anderson Silva is a
kickboxer right so he does boxing and
and it's in in some form and then he was
on the undercard with uh with Floyd
Mayweather not too long ago I know you
guys don't want to see aging boxers do
these things right they weren't getting
paid these these he Anderson Silva
wasn't getting paid he wasn't getting
paid the money that his caliber of uh of
fighting demanded right so if in this
fight he can get a 10 million
don't you Champion that don't you don't
you wish for these guys to have a
greater afterlife from the sport because
I'm watching the sports and some of
these uh some of our favorite dudes
aren't living the best after their sport
right so yeah I'm into the entertainment
aspect of it that they could make some
money I mean that's a good thing right
let me see
I'll be waiting for the boxing game
gotta be
the heat if you beat Sylvia he deserves
it but if Sylvia wins and his age you
know something will keep going on they
said to be taken advantage of the
taxation about living in Puerto Rico of
course I'm sick of Jake Paul if he wants
to act tough he needs the Box real
amateur boxes at his age range
um there's no money in that
there's no money in fighting a nobody
that's why when he was going to fight
haseem rachman Jr the money wasn't there
so you yeah you get a Anderson Silva and
that money is there so you have Anderson
Silva's crowd that he built up to get to
this stage and you know you bring in
your your fan base you bring in the
younger crowd so all us older dudes want
to see Anderson Silva beat the breaks
off him all the younger dudes is like
yeah Jake Paul so that's a great Dynamic
and then you bring in the contention of
Brazil and then you bring in uh the
YouTubers the young kids in from this
side so the money is there and they have
good undercards the production value is
very high it's not cheap right so you
you you got to give the the Brain Trust
behind it uh um
some type of Kudos right
If he if he would have thought I'd seen
rock my junior and lose the haseem
Rockman Jr just think about this
he loses to haseem rakman Jr there's no
money there
you just lost
and then you don't get the payday I'm
pretty sure the payday has a lot more
the same thing with Anderson Silva so
yeah Anderson Silva gets a check Jake
Paul gets a bigger check
people get entertainment we're here for
the entertainment Factor right let's
let's be honest this is just
entertainment this is absolutely nothing
else and if we if we do get something
fantastic out of it then we get
something fantastic out of it
um let me see GSP is next up yo my wife
was asking me that what the hell did
they have to uh introduce GXP for
GSP why
and I said uh he's there for a reason
is it a setup y'all I want revenge from
my friend type of thing it's it it's
it's something that'll be dope
the GSP needs a check too
yo and and I like The Classy
um outfits that they have the ring car
girls walk around with
um they're revealing but not too
flamboyant with it it looks more like
um
like a volleyball clothes
very cool stuff um very classy stuff I
think the whole card is put together
really well whoever does the production
behind the scenes with uh Showtime is
definitely doing the best I I believe
and and I think it's really good so we
have uh six people on Watch and let's
get that in 33 likes let's get that like
subscribe share push that out King David
the professional fan I'm gonna give you
what I see and I'm gonna talk about what
I know
let's see let's see Carolina what's
going on so he wants to skip the ground
and become a big name boxer he did that
already
yeah GSP yeah GPS uh he said GPS GSP cam
box he's a wrestler
still a UFC contract until this week
yeah first visit is a super pimp
collection you have thank you Gary thank
you respect all day
um
I love my statues all day I I really do
so much
um I switched most of my collection over
from Sideshow to XM studio uh statues uh
so the majority of them trying to get
rid of the rest of the sideshow that I
do have but there's some side shows that
won't go like uh my doom on throne and a
couple of others but um nah I'm trying
to switch over from there to just you
know straight XM Studio really love XM
Studio stuff
so we still have the lower weight
classes fighting right now
now if the main event didn't start and
lomachenko's main event is going to
start I will switch over to go to
lomachenko's Main Event real quick do
the main event over there like we did
with Devin Haney
uh last week and then Deontay Wilder we
can do that we can give we can give both
headlining cards tonight because tonight
is a very rare night where you have
boxing on two pay-per-view boxings well
Mama changles really not pay-per-view
that's just on uh fox or ESPN and you
have uh showtimes pay-per-view which is
this and you have uh MMA on as well so
and the Zone has a card this evening so
you have a a total package of uh big
time uh boxing and and Combat Sports
you know going on so we will if
we have two more cards because I believe
we have two more
um fights ahead
right now because we have Santiago
versus Nieves right now fighting and
it's uh bantamweight about of 10 Rounds
really really I don't really like
bantamweights very quick very soft
lighting himself
um but maybe you get something special
out of it but I don't call it the
smaller fights I call the large fight
the large fight I give you play by play
of what's going on and what's happening
on the scene
first visit let me see yeah my lawyer
will still be contacting you about
collecting my statues that's what's up
what's the status of the Ko's how is it
coming along oh um yeah well combat talk
with the King and um uh Kos is about to
go up we already uh finished that wait
when for the overlay uh for My Boy when
that overlay comes through then boom
statues show backup statue show back
going on and um like I have a ton of
statues that I haven't even talked about
like that doctor strange I wanted to do
the doctor strange when the doctor
strange movie was on but
you know it is what it is let's see
what's going on right now over at
lomachenko
versus the young bull
and see if it um
if we got something going on over there
before the Jake Paul Main Event all
right so we got lomachenko
all right so Devin Haney is talking
right now
and um he just handled his business
so how are you guys feeling
with Bud taking that fight with uh
I don't even know who that guy is uh
avistian David avastian
he was in con he was in talks to fight
uh to Spence but what the hell happened
like he pulls out to go fight slow-mo
back slap what's good baby
um he pulls out to go
fight David avocision
and doesn't fight Spence like that's a
duck move baby
so I I can't respect that at all once
you're in talks to have this fight that
we all wanted to see that happen this
year
and could have happened this year
now we gotta wait till next year but we
got bud fighting this dude Buck could
lose to this dude
and then Spence gonna fight this dude to
get that belts and and leave so
I don't know right now but Devin Haney's
right now is talking so hopefully we get
to see Devin Haney versus lomachenko let
me see what we got going on what's going
on TG dope
in the bushes the day he gave up the
belts to hanging like a victim my gut
said he duck yeah for sure he did
I was I was reading in Miles morale was
comic a few weeks ago and Dr Doom
appeared in it and he got Body by Miles
I'm very conflicted by that you know
damn well Doom would slap miles in half
it's all left up to the writers right
whoever's writing the book can dictate
what happens
um technically he's not even supposed to
be in Dr Doom's League Miles Morales is
a cool character
uh Spider-Man doesn't beat Doom doc the
Doom is a different type of Beast a
different type of animal how many people
saw a Black Adam
how you like that Black Adam I just
finished doing the Lord's uh minute and
talking about Black Adam spoiler free uh
uh little-known effect attic is coming
to New York next week and we're gonna go
see Black Adam again and
um we're going to probably do a round
table with a lot of people talking about
Black Adam and you know hopefully we get
a lot of people that probably either
didn't like it or had conflicting
thoughts on it
and we're going to talk about Black Adam
and its entirety and what Black Adam
means to the DC EU uh what where does he
stand in the hierarchy of things and
then after that we have black panther
where
I got a character that I've waited damn
near my whole life to see on the screen
I mean we I had Submariner that was on
TV with the web fingers and the web toes
if anybody remembered that but I get to
have name more
and he can't be the prince of Atlantis
because they had to change stuff around
uh copyright stuff but um
I have Neymar on the screen
and that comes from the story lines uh
Kings versus Kings uh with black panther
versus Neymar and I don't know how they
work this out I don't know how this
actually works but it looks incredible
to see it on screen to see him with the
wings on his ankles moving from side to
side as he attacks I've waited for this
forever and to get this on the screen
now is this is like a kid in Disney
World you know like this this stuff is
utter amazement so know that the books
that you're reading now let's just say
your younger kid right now you're
reading books right now know that
there's a possibility that what you're
reading those characters that you're
falling in love with right now could be
on that big screen
I saw Dr Fate inside Black Adam
I never thought I'd see Black Adam on
the screen
but then to see Dr Fate there
you guys my wife I was fanboying the
whole movie the whole movie was a giant
incredible dream for me let me see
King what's your favorite fight of all
time that you've seen and you still
remember that I've seen in person
oh oh that I've seen my favorite fight
of all time has to be Evander Holyfield
versus Mike Tyson right and and the
reason why is because I'm a huge Evander
Holyfield fan and everybody wrote off
Evander Holyfield going into that fight
and I knew that Holyfield can beat him I
knew it I knew it in my bones and I and
I made bets to to that extent and you
know I I didn't care and and to see it
happen how I said it would happen and
how he did it
and to knock him out was
like Glory
but um before then you know before that
fight you know um
I I don't that that one stands out the
most to me I mean you could say Tito
versus Oscar uh I wish that it was a
little bit more excitement and it it did
what it did but that ultimate
compilation was probably Holyfield
versus Mike Tyson for me Holyfield
versus Mike Tyson let me see
uh was Doom sleep when miles attacked
him going back to see going to see Black
Adam on Tuesday that's right black he
gets oh mushrooms gets about 6.5
now he saw he was wide awake Miles
Morales beat him with a Venom punch I
was reading it all hell no I've seen
Miles use that punch to slump black
heart it's incredibly powerful but I
can't see Doom losing that's crazy yeah
me neither
me neither but again it depends on who's
writing the book right so if if
you get the proper writer they can make
anything happen so
think about it this way
Dr Doom was so conniving that he stole
the power Cosmic from Silver Surfer
technically he's not supposed to beat
Silver Surfer right but whoever's
writing the book at that time can
actually write in anything that they
want to write and that stuff would
happen
but uh back to boxing guys back to
Combat Sports what fights are y'all
looking forward to going forward I mean
I would love to really see Devin Haney
versus lomachenko I definitely want to
see that fight happen and I think that's
a high possibility that we can get that
happening because lomachenko should win
tonight you know barring any weird
things that's going on and David Haney
already did cleared his hurdle so you
know and his heard it was the George
cambosa rematch all right let me uh
shoot back over here to
um
Jake Paul on the card see if they where
they're at all right the little guys is
still fighting man round three
and this should go on a period of time
like I said normally by like around 11
30 uh quarter to 12 we'll get to the
main event and that'll happen unless all
the undercards are Knockouts and it
seems right now nuevas is going after
Santiago at a hard Pace right now so
highly possible stuff let me see
right BMB wrote Iron Man beating Magneto
yeah that's ridiculous how the hell how
the hell can Iron Man beat Magneto
foreign
that should never happen
I don't I don't even see the scenario
where that can happen unless um Iron Man
gets a whole rubber suit and I
his whole idea is based off of
um Iron so like come on man Iron Man
versus like makes no sense
my favorite fight was Julius Caesar
Chavez versus Melody you know what let
me tell you something about that fight I
was sitting there with my cousin God
Rest his soul and I'm watching that
fight
and the whole time I'm going for magic
Taylor right I'm the whole time I'm
going from Ella dick Taylor no shame
but I'm watching and I'm like yo this
Chavez dude is is chopping this dude
and every so often Chavez are chopping
to the body what
Pace them
one two to the Head
left hook to the body walk
and he just kept doing it and the guy
I've never seen a single-minded dude up
until that point like I've never seen a
hunter hunter killer stalker in the
manner of Julio Cesar Chavez let's give
him his respect Julio Caesar Chavez
senior not Junior Julio Cesar Chavez
senior
in the prime
is a brutal bone-breaking dude right he
knows how to cut off the ring he knows
how to use his jab intelligently and his
right hand and his left hook was
something to be feared that left hook to
the body was something to be feared what
he did to my idol I like the Camacho
something terrible but that fight
Malik Taylor hit him with the kitchen
sink everything but the kitchen sink
if melject till it holds on and wins
that fight I don't think he has the
downward spiral that he has in his life
that fight excuse me single-handedly
affected both people in two different
manners
you had magic Taylor
go on a downward spiral
and you had Julio Cesar Chavez
Ascension
from that moment on
that's when he became when he was pulled
from under Mike Tyson's undercards if
you if you ever know Don King would
always have Julio under Mike Tyson's
undercards and would use him as that
vehicle Mike Tyson Julio Cesar Chavez
and then Julio started headlighting his
home call his own cards right after that
two complete
things happen to two people in that
fight two diversion paths if magic
Taylor Wins does Julio take a spiral
and Magic Taylor take that scent
two different things happen
crazy fight one of the best fights in
the history of boxing
um fantastic stuff good good that you
brought that up
damn you mean you're a hell of a fan
needs to rematch Salito and tiafimo
didn't he rematch the leader I think he
rematched Alito
um no he didn't fight uh Tia Fimo it
would be awesome for a young king to do
interviews with boxers like Tyson oh for
you King to do it because hell yeah I
would love that
it was Avengers versus X-men one pure
nonsense that's what's up what up what
up Grim bones my dude tank Garcia before
you lock back into boxing Marvel what
Marvel character do you want to see
materialize on the big stream or series
um I would have said before before all
this stuff oh they have done all of my
characters basically to be honest with
you they have done Black Bolt I got
Black Bolt right there right they've
done Iron Fists I've got Iron Fists
right there they've done Ant-Man got
Ant-Man they've done Winter Soldier
they've done the one that I thought they
would never do which is Moon night
they've done Hawkeye they've done Red
Skull they've done uh uh Doctor Strange
they've done these characters they've
done cable they've they've done a
Kingpin they've done Weapon X Wolverine
um the only one that didn't get there
yet in in the manner that I want him to
get there is uh probably Dr Doom but um
Neymar is the last character for me
they've brung characters through like
we've just saw a scar son of Hulk of
being introduced in uh she-hulk's uh
series that characters is is coming so
you know we we see these things
happening little by little and they just
show given enough time giving enough
space this stuff can happen I would have
loved to see that we're going to see
Adam Warlock right uh man
I really can't say we've seen The
Infinity Gauntlet there's things that we
we are going to see like I'm we're going
to see
oh well I saw a Stormbreaker
so beadery bill is probably somewhere
down down the road right
um
I I don't know I don't it's probably
just Nemo to be honest with you that's
the last dude let me see hold on y'all
guys it's moving fast today boy
let me see
all right 10 Garcia yes definitely want
to see that Chavez said an interview
that that fight was the hardest fight he
said he was an inch from dying I believe
you I believe you because watching that
fight that guy gave everything he had
both of them gave everything and I think
it that a loss in that fight
would would really hurt Paul you know
would have really hurt both you know and
would have had a negative effect
on both and it did it had a negative
effect on Mildred tiller I'm just so
sorry that it had such a negative effect
on him and then when he had the rematch
it was just it just wasn't meant to be
I want to see blue Marvel yeah blue
Marvel is I heard about that it's
probably coming soon
I want to see cables many cable series
man uh static shock not really a fan too
much who's fighting right now
um we have the bantamweights fighting uh
those are actually real boxes see they
do it smart and they actually put in
real boxing
with this entertainment stuff so this is
the Banta wage there scheduled for to uh
I think Santiago versus Nieves uh for 10
rounds in the band's weight Division and
they had round five right now again I
don't call the undercards unless it's a
power pack on the card uh fight that I
do want to talk about uh and again
bantamweights to be honest with you they
move at lightning speeds it's like
having lightning in a bottle and those
two dudes fighting with no Knockouts
just like Rock'em sock'em robots
can't wait to see Dr Doom that's right
so I'll move back blue Marvel can't wait
X-Men need a reboot X-Men is coming
X-Men is coming
all right so
tank versus Garcia those those
talks is ongoing
and I know uh we talked before when tank
fought
now since the since Garcia had that win
with that crazy left hook that we saw
who do you think wins that out of tank
versus Garcia do do we feel that Garcia
is a lock do we feel that tank is a lot
do we feel a tank's experience
um
put some over the edge or do we feel
that you know Garcia's uh height speed
and distance uh gives him the edge
or you know because it isn't Garcia I
think a little bit younger than tank
or do we feel that Tank's experience
ingredients and ability to box on the
inside gives him the edge
who has the edge in that fight
I tend to lean towards tank in that
fight right now
nuevas is a Savage
right he is uh boxing
Santiago something terrible Santiago is
moving from side to side and you know
they're up against the Rope but this is
pretty it's pretty entertaining to fight
I'm not gonna lie
um
but not what we came to see we came to
see Anderson Silva uh get that Victory
now
we can't see Jake Paul versus Anderson
Silva if it's a victory to be had then
it's a victory to be made right maybe
that happens maybe not
but wow that's that's a nice one too
this this guy is throwing serious
leather and uh oh sharp right hand
and he steps in uh with a left hook
right hand Santiago boxes off the back
foot throws a jab moves from side to
side and shoots a right hand over the
top pretty decent stuff this is stuff
that I like to see I like to see a high
level boxing and they put two high level
boxes in there
and you could tell by the foot movement
uh shoulder placement uh hand placement
not too much bouncing you know uh the
way you dip inside the way you hunt the
way you move even if you're being
stalked the way that you step away from
a shot and put your arms up in Perry
because you can Parry with your
shoulders and your arms and your hands
from side to side and push back and then
push forward so those little movements
those little subtle things allow me to
know what level that they're fighting at
right where they're fighting at so how
not to get tired how if you're tired in
the ring how to take a rest without
somebody knowing that you're taking rest
uh you got Luke right there his brother
Loop
uh
sitting there with somebody else and um
that's that I think they built something
really good you have Andre Birdo in the
crowd
I would love to see Jake versus Andre
Berto
that's what I would like to see if you
guys want to see him fight somebody that
can actually fight back uh and that's a
good fighter that's what I want to see
because you know a lot of people think
Andre Berto can't fight Andre Berto is a
serious fighter and you have a lot of
YouTubers there that uh some guys that I
don't know
that are there some MMA guys that are
there huge YouTube Contender they can
pack out a crowd that is crazy
they go Nick
Nick look like he just fought that I
look crazy
you know Chris cyborg
um I don't know what she did to her nose
she looked she did something crazy she
looks like a totally different person
king would love to see you do a future
video your favorite future Marvel Comics
would Paul ever fight a real
professional boxer is Jack gonna get his
head torn off Jake
checking in to make sure everything is
working yeah what up addict everything
working baby
um
if I can get a chance to see you know
who I would love to have interviewed
Stanley
on a lot of his choices back when stuff
wasn't
uh in a good climate because remember
they Stan Lee was doing comic books
during a racial divide uh you know
marches and stuff like that throughout
our country
and
Stanley always seemed to me as a a guy
that saw no color
you know a guy that uh always believed
what was inside the person I have a
statue there with a that's signed by
Stan Lee that's kind of crazy
right um it was a surprise from um a
friend of mine that I got the statue
from
and he he was signed by Stanley at the
bottom
incredible stuff you know to know that
Marvel was on the brink of being uh
gone
and DC is on that Brink right now
so we need uh Black Adam and these
movies to do good to Warner Brother can
sell them to somebody that's gonna be
you know viable because uh Discovery
doesn't want that stuff
we we want them to do good we want that
stuff
like we once Spence versus Bud
like we want uh Joshua versus Wilder
who's wildin's next fight
who's wildest next fight
it should be Joshua because we got Fury
fighting a fight that nobody cares about
because we wanted to see Fury versus
zusic and usig decided not to take that
fight for some weird reason so
again just like Bud
um well at least at least usick doesn't
have a fight lined up right uh bud is
fighting somebody that we don't know
um
the Normal public doesn't know
so and you have lomachenko doing his
warm-up fight tonight so hopefully he's
successful there in the next fight that
he has with Devin Haney and we can get a
chance to have that answered
and then the next person then the winner
of that can fight Shakur Stevenson uh
going forward and then we could just
have that round robin of those kings uh
getting that mix in right
and then we have uh tank versus Garcia
how does that shake out because I really
don't want to see tank fight nobody else
and I really don't want to see Garcia
fighting anybody else I want those two
to fight
and I really want Wilder and Joshua to
get it together they should have did it
together when they both had O's when
they both didn't have any losses on
their records and they should have just
had that fight
and I blame the promoters because I
don't ever think it's the fighters I
always think it's the promoters uh
protecting their assets
so now we're going to get this fight
where they're tainted and it's a little
bit less from each guy
I know you're going to say Waldo still
looks like he hitting hard on I got
reservations for that last fight I think
that was a homie that's my friend type
of fight to be honest with you but um
I want to see these fights I do want to
see Joshua versus Wilde I do want to
have the answers to that questions I do
want to see uh Garcia versus
um tank I do want to see Tio Fimo fight
anybody
and not George camposis Jr again no no
no I want to tell FEMA with his big
mouth to fight anybody I want um
Canelo to fight one of the Charles
preferably uh Jamal not Jamel Jamal
uh then we can have
um
who you say uh Jose benavidez Jr uh
versus uh what's this guy that just won
uh not too long ago uh cool hands uh
Jesus uh his name eludes me right now
but uh have him fight him this fights to
be made and these guys aren't making
these fights everybody's making these
substandard fights these fights need to
happen and I want to see them I'm I'm I
definitely want to see him
are you going back on the park yes sir
I'll be back on the podcast tomorrow sir
why the fighting rules Junior
um yeah
I think
I think that fight happens and the only
reason why I think that fight happens
is because the WBC wants that fight to
happen right
and if the WBC wants that fight to
happen
and it seems like Wilder is gearing to
try to get that title
by any means necessary
then a fight happens
so Ortiz Jr versus Wilder I think that's
a very dangerous fight for Wilder
I think I think I think Andy and Wilder
that's pure Dynamite
because Andy has firecrackers in both
hands right Andy I love
how Andy rips shots very short very
compact very it's like if he if he
parries something inside he'll take a
shot but he'll shoot that shot inside
and he'll turn it over so quickly and
you don't think that he's able to do it
and that's how he catches people off
guard you don't think he's able to close
distance he has very Swift feet not fast
feet Swift
in inhale slide up in on you throw that
jab and you you J you're misjudging his
distance and then the right hand comes
right behind it crack and he puts you
down
you saw what he did to Joshua
you you saw what he did to King Kong OTS
um Andy Williams Jr is uh very very good
inside fighter closing distance
and you gotta say
on outside Wilder is destructive on the
outside right
if Wilder can get distance on Ruiz and
punch down on Ruiz
can Ruiz take that shot
because what we're used to we're used to
Andrew Ruiz taking shots to give a shot
right
can he take Deontay Wilder's shot
not too many people have only I think
one person made it
and and that's Tyson Fury
or was it two people but he came back
and Avenged that and with a like a 30
second knockout of Bernie savine
so all right so the the fight is over
they called the fight on
um Santiago he's done Whoever has beat
him
um where one fight away from the main
event
and that should be some good stuff
right one fight away from the main event
but Andy Ruiz
can he
get in close enough
to give Deontay Wilder enough hell
hmm that would be something insane he
would he would have single-handedly
disrupted the apple cart twice because
remember he's the one that started the
dominoes to fall he's the one that
messed up the Deontay Wilder Joshua
thing because he went in there and he
beat Joshua
good cause the realm Miss King noted and
disrespect to the Lord's Walter eats his
spinach before his fights laugh out loud
yeah Kayla plant thank you Caleb plant
thank you for helping me man I do I do
respect that I would love to see
benavidez versus Kate up
Kayla plant I think Caleb is a
underrated fighter
um and I and I think that David
benavidez needs or deserves
to have that that big fight he deserves
it man the guy has been sitting out
there he's been fighting everybody that
people put in front of him nobody wants
to fight that big strong uh Mexican dude
nobody wants to fight him and they call
him the Mexican Nightmare and for all
good reason we have 74 watching we have
57 likes let's get those likes up let's
do that please
uh we got two fights to the main event
and I know everybody's here to see Jake
Paul do his thing everybody's here to
help me call Jake Paul versus Anderson
Silva
let alone uh
thing is I have a bias and um
I'm pulling for silver
who that Hollywood rules what's going on
that's my dude man everybody's pulling
up man this is this is what I'm talking
about this is what I like this is what I
respect you know just hanging out and
guys giving me some time and I'm trying
to give y'all the best uh something
something different but we're definitely
going to be there
um I just had a family issue last week
that's the only reason why uh I was
wasn't on the show and I was right there
like I got there and I and I had to run
back outside the house so um
you know stuff like that happens
hardly ever miss a show if any uh but um
again I hate missing and we had good
topics that I wanted to talk about I
wanted to talk about
um Helena with the Bayonetta thing
now we see
right
that kind of sucks that it hurts it
hurts it hurts
when somebody has a job and they feel
unappreciated and they see everybody
else making all this money and they feel
that they're integral to this process
and they don't get what they feel they
deserve and it just it hurts that it
went out this way and she has to look
like this in the public nobody wants to
look bad in front of the world you know
it sucks man let me see what we got here
people take us regret it because he's
fat but he's a good fighter I don't know
why they didn't let that being shown I
got you Marshall
um
yeah
yo Sony does stay giving me topics
I got I got uh my wife wanted me to show
something I'm gonna tweet something up
before I go upstairs
um I got the new controller in for the
new PlayStation 5 stuff but um
now uh
I I really wanted to talk about topics
last week I Microsoft Store uh that that
thing is huge the Microsoft store is
huge that's a huge thing
all right so they're clearing out the
ring and they're taking a Time clearing
out the ring they're talking to
um
uh uh Aryan Hillary I really like this
guy uh the MMA guy he reminds me of
Colin so much
um the way he's so professional the way
he attacks a conversation the way he's
analytical to things
um and logical at the same time it's
it's really good to see I like that
stuff and um the guy that calls MMA
stuff is really good stuff right I know
y'all know who I'm talking about
it's a log net once Jake Paul away yeah
yeah yeah it's his show he might win
right
but you always say go with the betting
dollar right and then that's that's
quite possible
but now that spins I don't know who
Spence fights right now because he
wanted to fight but so who does Spence
fight I want to see Spence fight
um
Keith Thurman but he won't fight Keith
Thurman he doesn't when he wanted to
fight Keith Thurman for the belt Keith
Thurman ducked him Thief Keith Thurman
talks so much crap and he told him he
will not let Keith Thurman make money
with him
I say break Keith Thurman down
that's what I say I say break Keith
Thurman down get Keith Thurman and give
Keith Thurman a beating that's what I
say
I say do that
um
but again I'm not in his shoes I didn't
have to deal with what Spence had to
deal with so does Spence go up does him
and Bud and I know bud would
automatically try to fight for one of
those belts down there
Bud would go around and mess around and
fight Danny Garcia get hurt
he will he wouldn't mess around and
fight one of those Champions like oh
guys and think it's a joke
and get hurt
and he would fight Thurman and get her I
think Bud understands a lot of things
and he's in he's very smart
by taking this other guy uh the Davidian
opposed to fighting Spence
that's that really sucks man I really
thought that we would get that fight and
I hope we do uh I'll be waking up
thinking it's a nightmare like I can't
believe that happened like the same time
you know when Mike Tyson was supposed to
fight Holyfield the first time and all
his other things happened when he lost
the bus to Douglas and you know
Holyfield had to go clean that up and
fight Buster Douglas and get the belts
and wind up having and then Mike had to
go to jail and uh he and Holyfield had
to you know defend for himself out here
and fight bow and and and all this other
stuff so
I don't know
um
we got good fights that's available good
fights that can happen and let me see
the lomachenko fight uh did
uh hopefully they didn't start yet
so we have uh three fights now we have
only two fights left for the Jake Paul
fight
let me see what's going on over here
with the lomachenko do we have
lombuchenko getting ready for the ring
now we have Ramirez versus uh Romero and
they're in the seventh round
um
you know I have to switch over to ESPN
Plus
they look pretty decent uh you have a
South Pole versus an orthodox so you
have to look out for the head clashes
that's what the referee is looking for
right now
Tom rank is not known for putting
together good undercards let's let's
keep it a buck their undercards really
suck for me
I think they they you know they try to
push uh uh just the headliner and to be
honest with you lomachenko is not really
fighting a real top name dude so they
give ESPN stuff to work with kind of
like the Zone stuff
you know so I don't think today we're
going to get a chance to go between two
main events because the undercards are
so short the rounds are so short on the
Jake Paul fight these guys are top
amount of rounds probably going is
um eight rounds like right now we have
Ashton uh versus uh stavel versus
Rodriguez that's the Dominican uh versus
I think that guy's black
and that that fight intrigues me
that undercard intrigues me all right so
we got Jake Paul talking right now
and he's talking about uh you know him
and Anderson Silva and
yo it's his face it's his face it's his
face
Jake Paul has a face that you want to
punch you wanna punch his face because
you know he's a bad kid you knew he was
a bad kid you know he was doing bad
things and you know he's just up to no
good and he has that mischievous face
and that's what makes it dope
what's going on care Sante what's going
on that's my brother saw your stuff
today love your stuff man better be this
has a strong attack but his defense is
not so good that's why I feel Canelo
would destroy him
um
see the thing about it is
benavidez
when you have a strong offense and if
you can keep your opponent on defense
for a long enough time
then you can win
what I see with David benavidez versus
Canelo if if Canelo doesn't wait during
benavidez which he can't
I don't think so
and if they fight at 168
I can see David benavidez
battering Canelo
hear me out
Canelo very recently with the injury to
his shoulder and injury to his knee
plays against the ropes a lot
right David benavidez excels against
opponents against the ropes he has
probably a 80 percent connect percentage
against opponents that play the ropes so
if Canelo was to play the ropes with
David benavidez
that would be basically a death sentence
right so what he would have to do is he
would have to keep the the fight in the
middle of the Ring now I believe Canelo
has enough defense that he can slip
enough shots to get inside to throw
those punches to the body not
necessarily the jab what you will want
to do is hurt David Benavides to the
body and shorten the distance on his
shots now if Canelo can actually walk
there with Benavides back I don't think
David Benavides fights good off his back
foot so if he can walk him down slip his
shots get inside to the body
and he can put Benavides on the defense
opposed to him being on the offense
that's the way I see
Canelo beating David benavidez and
that's highly plausible but at the same
time
I can see
benavidez young enough strong enough
and capable enough to keep Canelo at
distance and shoot his shots the same
way above all was able to do it to uh
Canelo and baval's defense remember
everybody's talking about the baval
defense wasn't all that good and baval
doesn't fight fantastic off his back
foot so remember all the same things
that I said about but uh David benavidez
before has the same
deficiencies
if David benavidez can fight the same
fight as above all
and push Canelo back at Key moments
there's and and I think David benavidez
hits harder or sharper than before
I think David benavidez can win that
fight and that's how he can win that
fight but is uh Canelo a live dog in
that fight yes you gotta look at age as
well canelo's getting up there so you
probably said he probably has at least
four or five more fights that he needs
to fight and then he's gone
then he's gone he doesn't need to be
here
he said I have so much uh respect for
old school boxes they fought into
someone almost died not just running
around the ring for 12 rounds
bear Baron was good
okay
um
I used to like 15 round fights
and the reason why I left I love 15
round fights you wasn't going to get a
draw
right you were you were going to get a
definitive winner
in 15 rounds separated the men from the
boys
very simple
if you have it or if you don't if you in
or you out
15 round fights to to people today
it would terrorize them but then you
would see who's the real champions
15 rounds is definitely needed so right
we have Jake Paul and they're showing
their records right now Jake Paul 504
Kos Anderson Silva three one and zero
with two Knockouts as far as boxes go
and Jake Paul's fighting a Cruiserweight
excuse me if I'm wrong did he start his
uh
his combat career at a lower weight
class in in at gradually grew into this
weight class
because I don't know I know his brother
should be heavier than him and the whole
thing with Floyd Floyd was fighting his
brother
at 30 pounds over Floyd's natural weight
all right kids aren't they have a good
evening brother my man peace
thank you for stopping by I appreciate
it all the time everybody everybody and
anybody to come through we have 69 with
73 likes oh my God y'all
they're making this dude cry right side
thank you I appreciate it all right so
they're setting up for the last two
fights and I told you the undercards if
they ended Knockouts it'll go fast it'll
get there look at that we're looking at
11 o'clock
right so we have this next fight that
will go probably no longer than a half
an hour
and then we're gonna have the main event
which will be uh Paul versus Silver
and that's that's sure to bringing the
fireworks let's run over to the
lomachenko
uh versus uh the young bull
to see exactly what's gonna happen there
what do what do we get there
let's see
uh Romero and um
Ramirez is still fighting here
okay so nope
I really wished and really hoped that
that would have uh transpired like we
did with the Devin Haney versus camboces
yo where does camposis go I mean I know
cam Bose has got paid a crap ton of
money
right where does camposis go from here
who do do we want to see cambosis versus
teal female I mean I don't want to see
camposis versus still female cambos is
beat him he doesn't need to fight him
again until femo needs to fight him
well for something I I don't know Tio
FEMA didn't look good in his last fight
but Timo Fimo uh
forgive me if I'm wrong Fimo went up in
weight
and he didn't look good up in weight
I think he should have went back down
and wait
oh gaming for yo Forte Forte
what's up man
I need you and some Destiny let me know
when you're on so I can so I can get my
destiny on Forte I need your help Forte
hey Forte I need your help man
oh he said oh I'm not out I'm here I got
the fight on my laptop screen I use your
color bro
that's what's up
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you
um
yo did y'all see okay so I put out the
other day did y'all see I retweeted some
I think this Tech Guy Cog put me onto
this dude
did y'all see the the the
um the Oculus Pro
did y'all see the cameras on the inside
that it could tell when your eyelids are
closed
or when you puff up your cheeks or when
you smile did you
I'm so envious of Lord Cognito right now
because you know shout out to my my my
my cousin
working for metal
oh man 814 with the five dollar Super
Chat hey King boo-boo hey Forte
yo that's what's up somebody got respect
hey also yo that cash out work that's no
joke funny me bank that's for real
though
that's a real thing the calling number's
supposed to be up there that's gonna
happen
um because remember we're doing
different things I want to do giveaways
oh yo did y'all go out and get any
pillows please tell me that y'all went
and got the Volari pillows please tell
me
that y'all went and got this wonderful
pillow please tell me that y'all are in
on this pillow please on God I'm telling
you right now we got something special
that we're doing
um this uh I use my pillow all the time
so please tell me that that y'all went
out and got it because we're gonna do
some stuff
and we're going to do some giveaways and
we're going to link that into it that
pillow's crazy I'm I'm and I know
somebody out there stopped the cap nah
it's no cap
that thing is for Real you'll see you'll
see it it's gonna It's Gonna Take You by
storm when when the first person gets it
and they post their pictures and they
talk about it because I want to talk
about it I'm gonna have a conversation
with people about it it's a different
it's a different thing it says how you
sit how you prop yourself you're gonna
see it's it's it's and and the quality
insane we have this thing that we're
doing next week and you're gonna get a
chance to see it because you're gonna
get a chance to see us uh do some live
stuff
Canelo is no ordinary boxer that's right
live Supremacy what's up my dude
there it is it's pre-ordered thank you
brother
thank you Necromancer I want to see
plant versus Benavides because I think
plant can beat them and can and Canelo
can KO plan and all right well Canelo
beat plant already
I um I don't think plant can beat
benavidez
y'all sleeping you sleeping on better
it's not y'all it's you you're sleeping
on Benavides you don't know why they
call him the Mexican monster he's he's a
Nightmare Man
is a reason why
Jamal hasn't fought him
yet
and I'm I think Jamal
and Jamel
are some of the best boxers we have in
those two respective weight Division and
154 160.
I believe
those are some of the two best boxers
boxer punchers they remind me of Terry
Norris without the chin problem
they they
remind me of
what what you want to see in a box of
punch or somebody that can box a little
bit around you
but always going for the kill always
lethal enough to throw that left hook
right hand or throw a straight jab that
can put you in your butt
um those type of Fighters you know
Spence Spence doesn't box like that he
spins is a pressure boxer right
these are boxer punchers
two different things
boxer punches they're going in there
boxing and they can punch they can knock
your head off uh Sprints is a pressure
boxer
right he can box you but he's putting
pressure on you he'll break you down
Mike McCollum style breaking ribs
breaking bones breaking orbital sockets
breaking shoulder joints all types of
crazy stuff but the the Charlo Brothers
will knock you out cold smooth separate
you from your Consciousness and I I
don't see them fighting David benavidez
and I think David benavidez has enough
respect in the boxing Community to to
have people take caution and stay away
from him or
or have no other choice but to fight him
what is this guy come oh he's coming out
with a Halloween costume he's coming out
with a um what's those uh minions
he has a minions costume on not Jake
Paul not Jake Paul that's the next fight
almost okay hold on
I have my hands hovering over the buy
button that question that Quest Pro but
wife gave me the eyes she reminded me of
e323 yeah
an avalari though pre-ordered that on
the deck thank you brother I need to
seeing him fight bigger fights this is
true
I'm with you but you can't get bigger
fights if people are not fighting you
right that's that's that's the thing
Marshall it's like
you have the the the the case of the
chicken or the egg right which gonna
come first somebody's gonna step up to
fight him and give him that chance and
let him in the door or
he's gonna toil in iniquities by himself
over there he has to put himself in
those positions to fight remember
you have boo-boo um uh Andrade Andrade
is available now if Andrade would take
that fight with benavidez maybe we can
get two or three of those fights and we
can see exactly what both of them have I
don't like andrade's Style
I'm not saying that it's not effective
but you notice how he fell out of the
conversation that we were having right
now and we haven't talked about Booboo
at all
and I I think that that's that's a
problem that's a boo boo problem be
honest with you because he has to insert
himself into these conversations he had
a chance to fight uh I think it was
Jamel
and he pulled out of the fight within a
week notice here it was like a week to
the fight he pulled out of the fight and
that fight could have happened you know
Jared heard uh ate his way out of a
Championship
uh it's a lot of things that used to
transpire when the PVC had tons of money
and they were fighting had Fighters
fighting all the time and I think uh you
know covet came and and took away from
that took away from us getting a lot of
those fights that we would have had then
right so now we're gonna have to have
Fringe fights I think these friends
fights
um
way heavy going forward so we definitely
need to see uh Kayla plant versus
benavidez but
do we get Andrade first Kayla plant
versus Andrade
you know those it's those three can mix
it up and we can see what happens from
there and hopefully they can pull uh
Canelo off the tree get a little Canelo
see what happens
let me see
I should be a promoter I need money
first
I need money first as a promoter you
need that cash so if I can get that cash
then I can promote like if I can promote
you know what it is you want me to be a
Matchmaker two different things
Matchmaker promoter I want to be I would
rather be a Matchmaker I would rather be
the person to set up the matches right
set up the the fights because then you
get a chance to see the best fight the
best because those those matchmakers get
a chance to watch fight tape on who
versus who right and match those guys
together then it's up to those promoters
to handle uh hammer out the deals with
the managers and then they once they
hammer out the deals we get the fights
so a good Matchmaker can put together a
fantastic fight
and guide two guys to to each other or
to to women yo shout out to the women
that fought two weeks ago Clarissa
Shields and the whole Squad uh Bumgarner
[Music]
um
um those fights
were incredible I implore anybody that
hasn't seen those fights to go back and
watch those fights those women put any
men to shame to be honest with you any
men to shame and it's it it was night
and day between the men and the women
and the women went out there and handled
their damn business and looked fine
doing it man I'm talking about some
Superior boxing with uh style and grace
beautiful stuff those women did
yeah I still believe that uh Deontay uh
gave his boy a good check
I
I'm sorry man I show me him do that
against uh Andy Louise Jr man
I'm sorry I'm just I
I know his record dictate I know
deontay's wildest wrecked dictates that
that's what he knew
I'm not disputing that
I'm just saying though come on man he
punched him from right here
um
and the guy fell out like somebody shot
him from across the street with a sniper
rifle
he punched him from right here
somebody told me deante got power of the
Gods
could be true
show me on Andy Williams Jr
and we know Andy takes some punches
let me see let me see let me see
we need you on the mic on the sidelines
bro I used to be banging to boxing when
I was younger but I fell off your color
got me back in blessings Bruce Lee said
yeah man wouldn't punch this dude all
right so oh oh okay yo
so right now we have a Seville versus uh
Rodriguez and
Rodriguez has a wild uh wide stance
right and he's sitting very low and he's
jabbing to severn's body
Severn has a a compact style left hook
uh off the vert not using the Jab
very light on the jab so he Jabs um
Rodriguez to the stomach this this fight
this is decent boxes right
and
yo yo
yo Rodriguez went ham
on stiver
s slid over and threw a uppercut and
knocked this dude out in the first round
I think he knocked him out he's not
looking well he's shaking the fight is
over
smooth that's that's the punch that I'm
talking about you you see what I'm
talking about Care Center you see what
I'm talking about watch the replay on
that punch care Sante the right hand oh
boy I told you oh boy ran out when I
said oh
and I was gonna call this fight when I
said oh he threw a right hand at him
that caught my attention from me talking
to you guys right caught my attention
now remember I don't call on the call
but if I see something that's going to
smack and I was smacking he threw that
right hand with the meanest of intention
I've seen Gerald McClellan fight that
boy hit him with a Gerald McKellen punch
and this is the Hulk Gerald McCullough
he
this boy
got some power you can tell
that he has he has a wonderful smile
hell of a powerful punch
they need the show to replay
we're going to get the main event a
whole lot faster than we thought but if
anybody's watching this
card
this young man
has bricks for Fists
bricks
he hid him
and I'm thinking it was uppercut because
it came from download could be a short
left hook inside
uh
but damn
I gotta see it again because he was on
the attack Rodriguez was
and
this kid was backing up Seville was
backing up
and caught him with a shot that
separated his consciousness
they gave him thoughts on do you want to
continue or do you not want to continue
are you about this life are you not
about this life
this kid got bricks in his gloves
figuratively speaking I'm talking about
his hands man his hands is made out of
some of the most powerful stuff that you
got going on that's enough metal right
there right there that's Infamous metal
he hit him with INF metal boy look at
this look they can show you the whole
first round over again right so he comes
out he throws straight to the dude body
right he throws straight to Rodriguez
body and they're standing in here
already has Rodriguez on his back foot
so Rodriguez is jabbing to his body
and uh Seville I believe I'm saying his
name wrong of course
um is in a high open guard but he
touches him with an overhand right and
there was a left hook right there that
he tried to land and against the Ville
is on the front Lead Foot and he Jabs
Rodriguez to the body to get his hands
lower right Jabs to the body again and
now here comes the right hand right
there catches him and he's gonna catch
him with a left hook it was a short
inside left hook that separated
Rodriguez from his Consciousness the
same way Garcia did through that left
hook and then his last fight it was a
short compact left hook Rodriguez was
too wide with all his shots he was going
after him
and
he didn't see that left hook coming the
left hook is ill right here talk Pure
Talk straight on the chin drop him
goodbye good night that's right go to
sleep and he was that okay the reason
why I thought he caught him with an
uppercut is because he threw a uppercut
like I said I'm pretty sure my eyes are
sharp and he and I thought he caught him
with the uppercut no it was smooth left
hook that he caught him with it wasn't
the uppercut that he caught him with and
dear God to see see Rodriguez hands is
too wide caught him coming in left hook
very tight and then see it was the
uppercut I thought he would have caught
him with that uppercut too he would have
separated the Consciousness he wouldn't
got up and he hops over him he puts his
hand on his back highly disrespectful
hops over him and gets out of the way
that that that's that's what I want to
see that's what I want to see
Andy would get skunked that punch you
can believe in none of that mythical
cheese stuff who punched who caresante
King hope you gentlemen have a great
Saturday what a wolf what's going on my
man John Wolf yes that's right hello
Supremacy good evening good evening good
evening
that's what I'm talking about
that that was something to see that was
something to see that was something to
see so
Rodriguez got stretched
Loma walking out right now but we're
about to get the main event over here
so uh Loma gonna have to stay walking
out
because we get a little in the main
event right here right now so again ah
didn't even know my chain was inside out
until I looked at it and touched it
right there I'm like it looks completely
dull what's going on surprise
inside out
left hook look at that left hook inside
and then he's gonna bring the uppercut
he was coming for the Doom with this
uppercut right here that uppercut
oh my God it's something about this
sport to make me so happy mono imano man
oh man pause that stuff right there
that's what it's all about that's what I
like to see
dear God he caught him with a nice left
hook boom he blocked this shot
and caught him with that left foot so he
had the presence of mind to be looking
at his foe while he was fighting
beautiful stuff that's that's what we
want to see
so we have Ari haleo
are Ari I remember when he was calling
MMA and he was doing it much like Max
Kellerman
much like on his own trying his best to
do it and calling good fights and he's
here
uh interviewing Fighters
I love that type of grind I love that
type of come up I love that type of work
that ethic that you put in that's
intuitiveness to something that crap
that you love what's going on
uh Corey Mosley you made it baby you
made it you made it
you made it right before the main event
y'all guys call for this y'all guys
asked for me to do this so
you know it is what it is we're about to
see this fight
we're about to see Anderson Silva
versus Jake Paul
and um
what it's gonna be
what is gonna be those baddies what is
gonna beat those baddies what's going to
be
hopefully
we get another knockout just like this
sweet knockout that was right here
this kid is Young he is talented
um
what you what you like to see when when
you have a fighter
he doesn't close his eyes
in the midst of battle a lot of times
you know dudes close their eyes when
they when they when a shot is coming
or when they throw in a shot they close
their eyes
this guy had his eyes open
when he was taking a shot
and he threw the left hook
that's
that's a guy that can stare down the
barrel of a gun
figuratively speaking
and don't have any fear
because those those are loaded those are
gloves packed with power with bad intent
and for you to don't Flinch in that
moment for you to have presence of mind
to catch
and Pitch at the same time
that's what you teach that's what all
the training is about that's what
sparring is about that's what met work
is about teaching you
catch pitch throw
side move he caught through and
automatically shifted and was going into
the uppercut so he was working on his
combinations he whatever he worked in
training camp worked on in training camp
it came out here
and this kid is no joke I gotta I gotta
really honestly respect his style
alright so we have Paul versus Sylvia
next
this is what y'all wanted this is what
y'all wanted to see so it's Ashton
stauville
versus uh berolio
Rodriguez I'm butchering names today I
feel like Lord attic I'm butchering
names today
but um of Jake Paul versus Anderson
Silva next
get this main event and y'all guys and I
get to call this fight oh my God
we are here and this is what we came to
see
oh siren Blakes what's going on
all right the man who got them horns how
you feel about the Paul Brothers listen
I respect anybody that can come from
nothing to make themself into something
I can respect anybody that comes from
adversity because remember Luke got
canceled and
he apologized and he built himself up
bigger better right
he didn't fall away he didn't disappear
he didn't shy away
he admitted his wrongs he paid his
Penance and bigger better better
I respect anybody that puts their feet
down and don't give up
you cannot give up on life you have to
push at every uh
um obstacle and these and these brothers
do that you know I don't have a brother
my brother's COG
right so
I was I'm only only boy
man
what it must be like to
share your life with um
somebody that you a brother like you
like you you know can you imagine all
the wild things that I was doing when I
was younger with with another little me
like a older
something
I I didn't have the pleasure of having
that I would have loved to have like
growing up but to see these guys do it
to see Jamal and Jamel
that stuff is beautiful that stuff I
mean if you got Brothers I mean and my
sister is seven years out for me seven
years so she's like very younger than me
you know so
um but if y'all got brothers or sisters
that y'all are really at close age man
y'all got to cherish that now cherish
that stuff
checking King I missed you last week you
making my time go buy my bad brother I'm
back baby
Jim Ryan closed his eyes when he found
out active she still love to hear your
coffee turkey
man I feel like Sylvia is gonna take a
dive I hope he doesn't
I hope Sylvia doesn't take a dive
you know what we what what we
what we want in our heroes
more than anything
integrity
it hurts our heart when we find out our
heroes did something that um
wasn't what
we hold there like you know like we we
expect Captain America to stand for
truth justice in American way right
that's that's that's what we expect Our
Heroes to stand for we expect Our Heroes
like Superman to never kill and find a
way
we expect these things
we have boxing Heroes
we have other Heroes that we that we
admire people that we admire
so the kid in me
not the cynic
they're kidding me
expects Anderson Silva to go in there to
be the warrior that I know him to be
that no amount of money can bribe his
integrity
that no amount of money can make that
man step on everything that he worked
hard for when he when he came from
Brazil when he when when he was grinding
that no amount of money
can purchase this man's Legacy
so yeah
I
the young kid in me
is hopeful maybe I'm naive
maybe I'm I'm dumb
maybe I'm stupid to believe this
maybe right
but that little glimmer inside of me
keeps me always watching
keeps me always believing
and yeah I know this is entertainment
and it's for us to be entertained
you know for a long time I thought
wrestling was real
you know I know it's a little bit of
acting here and there but you know as a
kid
this
I pray is real
and I respect Anderson Silva enough to
never question his integrity
so I expect him to go out there and and
do what I've seen him do for so long
just be that man
to be the most incredible guy that I've
seen
in MMA history for me
you know until other people came along
and he got a little bit older but
Henderson's open his prime nobody want
to fight him are you crazy
he's like Ali he's he's like Roy Jones
in his prime he's he is
like uh Pretty Boy Floyd he's he's like
Pacquiao in his prime he's
incredible those those guys our heroes
you don't question Your Heroes you
expect your Heroes to be who you expect
them to be
your hero
so this guy's my hero so if my hero win
lose a draw goes out there and get
knocked out Anderson Silva's coming out
right now folks hey this is so what's
going on right now
he got that black and gold on right
there baby it's yellow but it's black
and gold baby
oh man
see that stuff man hell no I ain't gonna
question that man Integrity please don't
do that please don't do that
oh man
yeah
I love this guy I love his Bullhead
himself
he should knock him out all this stuff
in the fighting Union if he loses
it's hard these days but we need to keep
believing in each other yes
Yes Man
we we do need to keep believing you know
so
you know they're showing him when he
knocked out Tito
when he got Tito Ortiz
[Laughter]
yo when he slumped Tito I knew he's
gonna slump Tito Tito look like he had
too many chips he he did a diet of
potato chips
his whole training camp
only thing that looked like the what was
he what was he called the the bad boy of
uh some Venice Beach bad boy something
like that only thing Tito looked like
was a big uh he just looked like
Megamind
oh God I'm definitely going to hell for
that one
all right so we got Anderson Silva and
and he looks fantastic oh wait a second
they oh man they fooled me I thought he
was coming out right now they was that
was when he was fighting uh Ortiz oh man
they they Bamboozled me I thought he was
ready to rock right then and there
[Laughter]
I thought he was coming out with that
black and gold that black and gold
looked sweet it's black and yellow but
you know IOP you know how I do you know
how I do black and gold I do wait a
second oh my Whatchamacallit is still on
I still got my green screen thing still
on
haha
I gotta turn that off add it we gotta
turn that off
all right so
let me run over here real quick check
out see what lomachenko doing before
these dudes uh get to run out real quick
let's see what lomachenko's up to
uh boy lomachenko lomachenko
what the hell
mama cenko got a cut
oh lombuchenko has a big knot under his
eye oh God oh God Eagles fan 96 what's
going on we almost got 100 people here
oh
lomachenko
what else what's going on
okay is old machenko gonna take another
round another loss round three
we got Ortiz that's on lomachenko young
bull
all right
all right Ortiz looks kind of strong
here lomachenko is trying to stalk them
uh Ortiz is moving left and right
lomachenko try to jab his way in
uh-huh
Ortiz with a Southport Jab
all right lomachenko is switching
oh man this this is a good one to see
oh
jab right hand okay
okay
oh my God
he's putting in the work on lomachenko
oh it's all right I think Roma machenko
should not have taken this fight oh my
God
oh this kid is definitely all right so
he did a triple jab right hand to the
body lomachenko stands in pocket
those uh a right hand left hook to his
face
good one oh lomachenko eye is bleeding
though
all right
very good very good stuff
let me know if Jake Paul right there is
definitely coming in we got 93 people
with 93 likes much respect to everybody
that's in here 100 thank you so much I
do appreciate everything coming out and
rocking with King the professional fan
100 I love it
listen
I do not want to get sucked into this
fight
but Imma tell you right now guys
uh
this fight right here lomachenko's not
looking too sweet very early and I'm
gonna have to uh come back and watch
this fight a little bit later but
lomachenko's not looking too sweet so
maybe and maybe not for lomachenko today
but what we got today is we got uh
Paul
and they showing Paul versus Woodley
right now
yo so they showed Paul versus Woodley
and you got respect Paul man Paul Paul
Jabs his way in he throws a right hand
left hook Paul's is trying he he's
not gonna sit there and and lay on his
shots he's gonna he's gonna put his
shots in yeah he lifts up
that's the punch to overhand right that
he caught Woodly
it's such a disrespectful shot because
Willy hands going he looks like he's
planking in mid-air and then he planks
so hard that he Planks on his stomach
absolutely dope stuff I love that stuff
all right so they showing his fight
Tyron Woodley KO uh Tyrone Woodley win
uh Ben asked that that Ben ashker and
stuff for stupid TKO
Nate Robinson KO and Ali Gibb uh TKO so
Paul's been doing Mad Knockouts uh his
five fights four knockouts good stuff
you gotta respect this stuff uh it's fun
it's fun it's exciting
it's something to watch
let me see
Galveston my dude what's going on
yeah man that's a great ratio right I
gotta respect the ratio
people come in put a like and they leave
and thank you that's
respect if you if you can get a hundred
loyal friends then that's something that
you're working with and I appreciate it
I appreciate it at all times more than
you know well this arena is packed and
it's full
they didn't come out yet
um I think they're still working on it
I'm the the fight junkie in me is gonna
run back and go see what the hell is
going on with lomachenko because the
fight junkie and me can't believe that
lomachenko is losing right now to Ortiz
or perceived to what I was seeing
so they ran for and Ortiz is attacking
lomachenko and they're back in the
center of the Ring lomachenko slides in
and he throws a right hand catches Ortiz
to the side of his face
um
all right so Ortiz is jabbing throw the
right hand left hook
lomachenko's uh what is that his right
eye is cut as a abrasion against it
lomachenko stepping up his speed right
now and he's attacking Ortiz the young
bull
and Ortiz backs them off with a double
jab moves him back into the center of
the Ring and uh lomachenko does a
shifting move with his feet but doesn't
throw a shot
uh-huh and Ortiz is very loose very in
control he's uh hitting lomachenko while
they're in the break on the break no
respect for lomachenko uh status
left foot to the body
very smooth and aggressive with his
style ortizes I'm not familiar with
Ortiz as a fighter but lomachenko
catches him with a sharp uh left inside
with a right hand jab remember uh but uh
Ortiz catches him with a 1-2 backs uh
lomachenko up and he's stepping on him
he's stepping over throws a 1-2 and he
steps over Ortiz looks very good he
throws an up uppercut in between the jab
he wraps up lomachenko's arms and he
steps back lomachenko steps in throws a
sharp left hook to the face of Ortiz or
cheese grabs and goes right back to his
Jab
lomachenko throws a body shot steps in
and grabs uh Ortiz Ortiz spins out
and throws a right hand
all right that's what I want to see if
Ortiz can keep Pace he throws a left
hook up a cut and throws some hooks on a
grab they're holding right now referee
is about to break them up oh no they
broke up theyself
and I go right back to a jab I gotta
respect lomachenko and Ortiz Ortiz
throws a right hand left hook and goes
right back to a jab goes right back to
up jab right hand left hook and he's
working lomachenko with shots it left
hook body he's throwing body shots he
sits lomachenko low he doesn't care he
hits little machine over the left hook
this is what you want to see
this is what you want to see you want to
see the young bull the young Puerto
Rican bull fighting his heart out this
is fantastic stuff this is what you want
to see
but I gotta shoot back over here to Paul
um
because I want to get that fight as
they're coming out that fight is going
to be short
our fight is going to be brief I think
that fight is going to not go the
distance at all
all right and they're still talking to
Paul
outside okay they're not ready yet all
right
um gonna shoot right back over to
lomachenko in between the rounds listen
guys we gotta do it this way because
this is compelling boxing stuff but
we're not going to miss Jake Paul and
Anderson Silva at all
what's going on Carolina
here we go 85 watching
let's do it
all right
gotta respect these guys okay so we're
looking at what is this uh
round five lomachenko comes out and he's
jabbing and he throws a left hook right
hand
all right a right hand jab from
lomachenko right to the body he goes
right in right hand he goes right into
the kid's body
kit steps over
and uh he tries to bully him but uh
Ortiz pushes him back
good job
see what oh nice sharp uh left hand from
uh lomachenko lomachenko catches him
with a one two steps in so now you see
the footwork of lomachenko lomachenko's
high guard stalking him he's standing in
close and he's moving in with short Jabs
right hands he's throwing three to four
shots as he steps in so he steps in with
a short right jab left hook right hand
right there we go uh and we have Ortiz
trying to match him he goes straight to
lomachenko body to take away his speed
shoots the jab straight up uh through
machenko's guard and throws a right hand
over the top young boys stalking him
right now they're coming in young boys
uh the flashy he's doing a bolo punch
with his right hand and he shoots the
jab straight over with his left all
right here we go
jab right in the middle young boy throws
uppercut in the middle lomachenko
catches him with a right hand inside
tight
so here we go back to it lomachenko goes
with the right Jab
all right and Ortiz Jabs him throws a
right hand
right to the body into a clinch referee
breaks them up they go right back to it
again
so we got a jab from Ortiz I know cheese
is up against the ropes though while
lomachenko stalking
um in and out lomachenko's going in and
out they're both jabbing each other left
hook from Ortiz
or tease those two Jabs two Jabs and
right hand one two three shoe shine uh
um lomachenko in the center to the ring
lomachenko catches them with a 1-2 in
the center to the ring with a right hand
all right good right hand lomachenko
right there Ortiz is right there they're
pouring jabbing they're using feet
footwork both of them all right
lomachenko tries to catch him with a
sharp left
we have 33 seconds left in the round
Ortiz is stalking lomachenko throws a
1-2 lomachenko tries to put him to sleep
with uh right hand he misses
22 seconds left in a round
nice jab from Ortiz
straight left hand right hand
all right lomachenko is fighting I think
this best round for Ortiz but again
Ortiz goes right to lomachenko's body
he's not fearful he throws a left hook
over the top and he goes after uh
lomachenko that was fire stuff that was
fantastic stuff good stuff that I like
to see let me get out of here let me run
back over here to RTS I mean um
Paul and Silva let me check and see if
they fight is ready if they're coming
down the pipe
they should be walking it out right now
let's see
nope it's still not in the ring yet
still not in the ring yet that this all
right so Paul is in the background still
warming up we probably got one more
round
over here
with uh lomachenko nrts
all right one more round with a little
machine going Ortiz and then we should
have the main event remember they got
sponsors and stuff like that they got
time slots that they have to do so if
they uh plan to go out at 12 or a little
bit later then they will do so but right
now Ortiz I mean lomachenko and Ortiz is
in a great battle round six right now A
Loma chain hole comes out boxing and
shoots a straight left hand in a um a
straight jab two Ortiz right now
lomachenko is fighting hard all right
he's backing up Ortiz he's throwing ones
and two throughs the guard of Ortiz
Ortiz backs uh lomachenko with a jab and
a straight right hand and he's circling
lomachenko they're back in the center of
the ring uh again
a young boy throws a nice jab up jab to
lomachenko good footwork I love the
footwork that Ortiz is showing he throws
a nice left hook he is very seasoned to
be so young this kid looks very well uh
groomed but lomachenko comes back in
with a nice right-handed jab all right
and they're pairing jabs back off of
each other lomachenko has room to work
he pivots it's off of Ortiz but Ortiz is
standing right there with a nice jab in
his face Ortiz is in the middle
lomachenko shoots uh left hand straight
down the pipe and catches Ortiz Ortiz
throws a 1-2 misses
in the center of the Ring
all right here we go
so we got uh oh one two from uh Ortiz
catches along with chainco coming in
lomachenko has Ortiz up against the Rope
or T fights off the Rope then holds
lomachenko until they come to a break
good stuff good stuff right here
lomachenko uh leans in with a short left
that catches Ortiz Ortiz backs him up
with a nice jab they're close to the
ropes lomachenko looks like he has more
energy his jab is coming over the top of
Ortiz has Ortiz eye puffy
all right one two from Ortiz left hook
from Ortiz to the side of lomachenko
head one two from Ortiz again
lomachenko throws his 1-2 and catches
Ortiz
same so they're trading one twos at this
period of time
and you have Ortiz again picking up his
foot I love the Moxie on this kid all
right he steps around
um lomachenko while he's hunting him
nice one too jab one two uppercuts all
inside someone's um lomachenko holds he
throws uppercuts inside very smart Oh
short left hook catches lomachenko short
left foot catches lomachenko as
lomachenko's coming in homachinko is
stalking him though don't get it wrong
all right so Ortiz throws a jab
lomachenko throws three punches to
Ortiz's body he went straight to his
body
all right good stuff Loma Chico's jab
and one two these guys are trading shot
for shot Ortiz is going ripe oh he
catches lomachenko backing up with a jab
and throws a left hook and that ends the
round that's what you want to see this
kid eyes getting a little bit swollen
but again he's given all he can give and
that is what you asked for in a young
fight of fighting a veteran of
lomachenko's status
beautiful stuff to see let's get back
over here to Jake Paul let's see if Jake
Paul and Sylvia is walking out Sylvia is
still warming up in the background
they're not walking out yet they're
still warming up all right uh and then
you have uh Anderson Silva he has the
black and gold official black and gold
on right now Jake Paul is still warming
up all right I don't know if they're
waiting for this fight to end for they
fight to begin but I don't think I think
it's probably professional courtesy
Maybe
but again
we got round seven coming up on
something fantastic
all right here we go
so one two from lomachenko in the center
ring and they're back at it again we
have round seven lomachenko steps in
with a double jab remember lomachenko
Southpaw uh oh
the kid turned South Paul went right
back at lomachenko oh oh oh
this kid is is throwing a ring he's
fighting just as good as he fight in
orthodox
beautiful thing beautiful thing
looks good
catching lomachenko to the body
very good stuff here all right so you
have Ortiz
throwing left hooks homage lomachenko is
straight hands straight right hands and
straight left hands very good looking
stuff right here
about breaking them up they're back in
the center ring
all right so
here we go
there we go
there we go straight jab from Ortiz
right hand very good stuff
oh left hook one two three from Ortiz
lomachenko comes back in with his jab
right hand good catches uh Ortiz at the
side of his head then he throws a nice
inch close left hook that catches Ortiz
flush
one two three from lomachenko lomachenko
stalking them High Caliber stuff
pitching the right hand over the top
like a baseball player but same thing
with Ortiz Ortiz is throwing one two
threes goes to lomachenko body
lomachenko doesn't take body shots well
off of a third shot he caught him with a
good shot and lomachenko's walking it
off
Ortiz comes right back to his body
throws a jab
is leaning at shoulder good good job
lomachenko is right there
left hooks right hands
there we go good good from lomachenko
good job
all right and Ortiz went right back to
southpaw
Minnesota ring
all right here we go
a nice jab from Ortiz Southpaw jab he
switches he moves right back around
lomachenko catches him with a short and
close left hook and goes straight to his
body
momachenko's walking around him goes and
Ortiz goes to a jab lomachenkos catches
the Jab
and he's coming after lomachenko but
lomachenko seems to be winning this
round
lomachenko has done the most work in
this round
you have uh eight seconds left in the
round
as Ortiz tries to stalk him lomachenko
holes throws the left hook round is over
fight should be starting right now
with
Paul
and Silva
let's go
all right
they're still doing promo they didn't
get to the fight yet they're still doing
promo
load my head hunters after seven Ortiz
Loma Spar and partner that's why he's
comfortable with him didn't know that at
all
did not know that at all
that's kind of crazy and that will
explain why he looks so uh comfortable
while he's fighting him
I think they're going to wait for this
uh Loma fight to be over folks I don't
know if that's what they're waiting for
but again we're right back at the Loma
fight
all right
um
We're not gonna miss anything because
remember they have to do national anthem
we have Devin Haney that's there
all right um Undisputed lightweight
champion
Undisputed all belts right there reside
with Devin Haney and he's looking at
lomachenko fight right now
round eight
oh so all right so Loma throws a a jab
left hook right hand
Ortiz slid back throws a jab
right jab he's in the South Pole stance
as he spins on laurenchenko and throws a
jab off the spin throws a 1-2 on
lumbuchenko spins a lot of roughing up
lomachenko at this moment right now as
far as holding twisting and grabbing
lomachenko is still in a high guard with
a jab and Ortiz catches him with an
uppercut but lomachenko catches him with
a short right hand inside
all right Ortiz lomachenko I love
lomachenko's overhand right or t throws
uppercuts inside Anytime lomachenko
holds all right left hook to the body
for more T's Ortiz steps in on
lomachenko throws a right hand
lomachenko catches and throws a left
hook they are very high close in
punching
um low boil there we go left hook right
hand from Ortiz Ortiz switches to
Southpaw and back to off the docks
good oh good shoulder block that he hit
lomachenko with push to lomachenko back
all right lomachenko throws a one two
three on his gloves
and Ortiz does the same exact thing
right back to lomachenko
good good if if it's what you say and
they are sparring partners this would uh
be the reason why they're so comfortable
with each other right now
because these guys are going every time
they hold Ortiz throws uppercuts on the
inside and I think that's integral to
his plan
nice job from Ortiz lomachenko High
guard shoots a jab steps over and Ortiz
isn't there
Ortiz has a lot of footwork this is my
first time seeing Ortiz in this
magnitude and he looks really
comfortable at this place uh one two
three and he catches lomachenko with
lomachenko catches him with a 1-2 and
they go into a hold
nice left hook to the side of his head
from lomachenko
lomachenko goes back to a jab High guard
and Ortiz goes back to a Southport
stance uh low guard hands very low to
his waist
21 seconds left in a round one two three
and he tries to catch lomachenko with a
jab looks very good
in doing so very good footwork for both
guys
they're holding
on the break Ortiz catches lomachenko
and he attacks lomachenko going
backwards very good stuff
again I love it I've can't say I don't
see the Moxie and this kid this kid
looks very good let's see if we have
Paul coming out right now
all right here we go
that fight is over for us we have Paul
coming out right now
he said late night King with the r b
voice
all right
here we go here we go people
that place is packed don't tell me that
this kid can't sell out an arena I don't
give a damn if he only got five fights
I wish somebody had turned out for me
like that I'll be fighting too
you see this here put me on one of his
undercards
I box King thrash
ah
what's going on Black Spot in game
what's up what's going on
he said boo Paul
is in the ring right now
that's what's up Paul is in the ring
right now that's weird he he took the
backs up to he learned Anderson Silva
work walk out uh next
that's a lot of respect
that's a lot of respect
Anderson Silva is 47 years old uh Jake
is 25.
wow
wow
wow that's crazy
that is absolutely nuts that's crazy
let's see what happens
Stanley what's up why my heart beating
so much bro
so you'll pay to see that fight
they put it up I'll fight it
yeah
and I go in there with my Xbox channel
oh God
[Laughter]
oh my God
OH Anderson is in the ring already okay
I thought he was letting him come on
second all right all right okay because
I know
um Paul's the east side all right
fight is happening right now brother
I love that um
that outfit Anderson Silva has on
Paul's stuff looked nice too
top this this is
this is what you want you really want
Anderson Silva to have to achieve this
crowd
um to get this payday you really want to
see this
um
for him
right for him
all this is possible
by Jake Paul
and with him and his brother
has achieved in a space
five fights
selling out
on Arena
on Showtime pay-per-view
let that sink in
let that sink in a little bit
we're talking about
what he's achieved in such a short
period of time in this space
is unheard of so do not tell me
that that you can achieve whatever dream
it is that you have
go get it
go
get it
because it's there for you if you can
think it you can achieve it if you can
say it you can believe it you can make
it happen
remember words of spells
so what will be my boxing name
he said I might pass out on me 4 am in
London are you going to stream it on
this channel
what this fight
what are you trying to give me a
copyright man
you're trying to give me a strike
you can see the fight
in my glasses can you see it can you see
it because I know a lot of times y'all
think I'm gonna wear somebody thought I
wear shades 24 7. ain't nothing wrong
with my eyes man what's wrong with you I
don't need no shade I put shades on
because I'll be tired when I'm on that
podcast that podcast five hours
five hours I'll be tired most of the
time I'll be up all night see right now
y'all think I'll probably go to sleep
not gonna happen I'll be up by the time
I get to the podcast ready to go
so they talking pulling right now here
we go
Talking Paul in he psyched up
you see
you you gotta you gotta your mind gotta
believe you gotta talk your mind through
it
you got to talk your mind through
everything
kid look ready
gotta respect this kid
hahaha
that's so beautiful that's so beautiful
when who's the Drew he's a winner
win lose a draw he's a winner
checks cash baby wouldn't lose a draw
he's a winner
he said I might restart a I missed when
I was training back in the entire boxing
hell yeah man do it
who do I think will win what in this
fight right now
I want Anderson Silva to win
I want Anderson to win if if you're
asking me what I want I told you I come
in with a bias I've been watching this
guy fight forever I want Anderson to win
no disrespect
this kid looked good
he looked like he realized something
Anderson looked big as hell boy
look big as hell boy
there you go I think Jake understood he
stepped in some boo-boo right there but
he stepped in some boo-boo boy you got
that boo-boo on your foot boy you smell
that
starting to stank boy
he said I fight Paul for losing money
here we go Anderson
time to Buck up baby
gotta get in there you gotta buck up
Don't You Buck up on me boy
all right
and this thing comes down to nice South
Pole
steps around
he's slowing Paul down
can Paul a fight at his uh at his pace
Paul's throwing the jab but Anderson is
not engaging
standing on the outside giving him faint
trying to Parry
so
Paul lunges in with a jab to the body
but Anderson isn't there he parries and
steps over
Anderson is not letting distance uh be
cut
because he puts the jab out there
but Paul is doing what he's supposed to
do to cut distance he shoots a wild uh
left
Anderson isn't there
he throws a double Jab
from the side Anderson isn't there
he catches the Anderson with a jab uh
right hand to the stomach
Anderson is backstepping this whole time
nice jab to the stomach from Paul
Jake is trying to cut the distance on
Anderson Anderson just keeps stepping to
his left
Jake Paul throws a right hand over the
top
blocked
throws a left hook missed
now Anderson is bouncing
like he's gonna mount an attack
he's slipping
showing his hands
and it's in the stand in his ground now
he's no longer giving up ground
and he's hop forward on Jake
it's like he's waiting for something
Jake throws a strong right hand Anderson
moves over
back to the center to the ring Jake
throws a jab misses
back in the center of the Ring
the parrying Jabs Jake wants to land
that right hand so bad
all right so Anderson throws a left hook
hits Jake Square in the jaw
Jake double Taps his jaw and says come
on
Anderson's touching the glove
they understand to the ring not too much
is happening but what is happening is a
lot right Anderson looks like he's
measuring him to see what he can get him
to fall for
all right they get into the first clinch
and the round is almost over eight
seconds time is ticking
they touch gloves
round is over
not too much being shown there but a lot
was being done there right Anderson is
measuring him Jake's trying to find a
[ __ ] in the armor to get inside to
throw his shots
very uh predictable round from what we
thought we were going to see
and we didn't expect Anderson to go out
blazing trying to attack him and we
expected Jake to try to find a way to
get inside
that's what happens
yes if he dies he dies
is DeSean wearing off a Jake Paul
doesn't mean he seem like he could sell
pay-per-views like several years ago
what's up what's up I think after the
first Anderson ain't trying to knock him
out he felt like he dodged the punch
I think
now we get to see what Anderson was
training on in training camp now
see Anderson has a nonchalant look to it
all right Jake comes out
any Jabs and
Anderson Jabs now Anderson is on the
stalking
and he's hunting Jake Paul
now Anderson is parring with the jab and
he tries to throw the right hand and he
tries to catch uh um Jake Paul he's
telling tap him to get off of him
and Jake Paul grabs
Anderson is walking him down now
trying to land the right hand
he lands the right hand and left hook to
Jake Paul head
all right he Jabs he's trying to throw
the right hand now Anderson is coming
for the kill on Jake he throws an
uppercut catches Jake in close Anderson
is uh is tightening up his hand Jake
Paul throws a right hand left hook
Anderson stands right there and he's
after Jake he has Jake against the ropes
he throws a left to Jake body Jake's
moves Anderson and Jake grabs he says
come on come on come on don't hold don't
hold now baby let's go this we gonna do
this fight Anderson is fired up Anderson
we're gonna say we're gonna do this
fight we're gonna fight this thing right
here boy this is what we're gonna do
Anderson gets on his toes and starts to
bounce on him bounce on him [ __ ] just
bounce on him and he's going from side
to side looking like a young Cassius
Clay that's sweet boy sweet
Anderson is dancing on them dancing is
in the middle so Anderson is going right
back to his jab good posture jab left
hook
Paul tried to land the right hand
Anderson lands a a left hook on the side
of Jake Paul hey and he switches to
South Pole and now he switches to
Orthodox oh he catches Aaron in some
silver with a right hand he tries to
catch him with a left hook Anderson puts
his hand down and said what up baby
what's going on what's really shaking in
this Hood so they back in the center to
the ring Anderson silvans go back to the
mixing you know you move your hands
you're getting that mix and he's getting
there in that mixing so there we go Jake
Paul and he's getting along Jake Paul
he's getting along on the kid he's
getting low spider low spider low he
running up on him
he's flexing his arms and Jake Paul is
ducking back
all right come on Jake come on Jake show
them Jake show them what you got baby
show them what you got little mama over
the hand
overhand uh uh from Anderson Silva Left
Foot Right Hand from Anderson Silva he's
kind of mauling Jake Paul in this round
right here Jake Paul said we're gonna
hold you off right here we're gonna slow
your old behind up because you got too
much energy right now
so did you take your Geritol right hand
from uh Jake Paul Anderson caught it
right now Anderson is right there in the
mix shoulders in those are left hook
catches Jake Paul mows them up against
the ropes Jake Paul grabs pushes him to
the middle of the Ring
Anderson comes back tells me come on
let's go stop playing around Jake Paul
tries to throw some punches grabs grabs
uh-huh Jake Paul's holding them hitting
Anderson is moving his head
that round has to go to Anderson Silva
excuse me that round has to go to
Anderson Silva
that's what we wanted to see
Anderson Silva acting a goddamn fool man
that's what we wanted to see everything
right there he pulled out every trick in
the book on him and that was looking
good he tapped his toe to punch him in
his face that boy is crazy he tapped his
toe to punch him in the face only person
I see do that was Roy Jones he missed
the shot he missed the shot Roy Jones
hit the shot he missed the shot but Jake
Paul caught him and Anderson slipped to
the side and did that face did that
slippery slide thing
doesn't look like uh Anderson could take
a Jake's power
all right Anderson is right there
I never thought Anderson had the
Fantastic chin anyway he just never got
hit
we never knew
all right here we go
Anderson back to jabbing in the center
to the ring
Paul is jabbing
Anderson's back to jab and Paul is
jabbing
Paul is putting up their hand to block
Anderson is driving Paul punches him
straight square into the stomach throws
a left hook over the top Anderson
catches that catches Paul straight to
the face
Anderson is going right back to Paul
body Paul can take some good shots boy
that boy is strong boy
he bucked strong boy Young Buck
Anderson switches to South Pole when he
goes to Southport he has he's
susceptible to get hit and get hurt I
mean when he goes to Orthodox he's
susceptible to get hit and get hurt but
when he's in South Paul he does way
better Anderson Silva that is myself
all right Anderson Silva is stalking him
throwing right hand left hooks Jake Paul
is backing up uh huh
Anderson Silva catches him with a short
left hook
uh short right hand Anderson Silva is on
Jake Paul
he's giving him a lot of the business
all right left hook to the side of the
head I mean right hook to the side of
the head right hand from Jake Paul Jake
Paul tries to catch Anderson Silva and
uh Anderson Silva catches him with a
left hook right hand
nice jab nice for Southport jab from
Anderson Silva
left hook from Jake Paul Jake Paul's
trying to set him up with that right
hand by Anderson Silva walking in very
sneaky shot very sneaky shot Anderson
Silva better look out for the Jake Paul
sneaky shot Jake Paul oh catches his and
the Silva coming in Jake Paul throws a
1-2 Anderson Silva's right there he
catches and silver with a right hand
comes in with a jab
Paul is on the attack now
Paul is trying to come in with that
right hand Anderson Silva throws a 1-2
silver Perry's a jab Perry's a jab
Paul is coming in now now Paul is coming
in Paul wants to land that right hand
good stuff 45 seconds left
round number three
Jake throwing the Jab
Anderson is on him
throws a left hook right hand
good hold from Jake
Jake is working it Jake is trying it
Drake tries to throw that right hand
check that kid check those that right
hand this is right there so now buddy
right there inside punching I said nah
buddy
both these this is entertaining I'm not
gonna lie I can't even lie this kid
entertaining right here from Anderson
left hook from Anderson
oh right to the body and they break it
up this boy is looking good
you got that 47 verses that 25
smells delicious smells delicious that's
what I like
Paul's tired yeah but he's they working
though they working though kids they
they look good they look good I can't
it's a good matchmaking it's good
matchmaking it look good
they working though you see that
Anderson looking good in there we got
105 watching we got 112 likes share that
out that's King David a professional fan
you know what we doing tonight we got
Jake doing it with Sylvia y'all ask for
we got it
it's on demand for you
oh
Jake catches him with that right hand
what Jake put everything into that said
boy I am not that kid like that
ate that shot so thank you sir my have
another
let's go tap up let's go round four of
eight let's do it
back in the center to the ring Anderson
back on his toes Jake out there throwing
that jab he trying to land that right
hand left hook Jake tried to swing both
of them that was good Jake fantastic
stuff boy get in there
Anderson Silva is trying to slip trying
to show him different things
they're right there Anderson Silva's
trying to stalk right there putting a
hand in the jab up in high trying to
distract him don't fall for that Cobra
shot there there Paul don't fall for
that Cobra shot
that's right nice job oh nice left hook
from from Jake he missed both of them
but that was a nice one man good attempt
good right hands good attempt good
attempt I think Anderson is bleeding
from his nose man if I check me if I
check let me see let me see
oh
all right so Anderson keeps going in
keeps stepping back keeps going and keep
stepping back
let me go there we go
Jake looking good Jake he got stops
throwing out that right hand when he
throws that jab you gotta stop pushing
it back look like you're doing Superman
punch gotta cut that out
good job come on come on get back in
there man mix it back up come on guys
that was doing so good last round
I know you're both ain't tired Anderson
throws a right hand I mean a left hand
South Park keeps messing me up
all right oh Jake catches him with uh
with a jab and over oh up a cup from
Anderson they're fighting uh-huh Jay
keeps jabbing strong stiff Jabs to
Anderson's nose
trying to bop that nose
Anderson has Jacob against the ropes
Jake keeps backing up Anderson keeps
stalking
Anderson backs up
Jake pushes those gloves together Jake
wants to land that right hand oh left
folk from Jake Jake misses that jab
Anderson Ducks low
Anderson uh Jake nice jab to the stomach
right hand to the stomach left hook
right hand left hook from Jake Jake
looking decent in spots
Anderson trying to slip those punches
trying to come in
he got Jake up in the corner he messed
with a right hand
I mean a left hand South Paul keep
messing me up I do apologize folks
so excited
Anderson's coming in
jabbing
nice Parry
oh Jake throws a left [ __ ] misses look
good on paper
good job from Jake
Anderson's following Jake inside
tries to throw left hook round is almost
over here's Jake with a right hand to
the side of his head Jake there's a one
two to the body into the head Anderson
is working on Jake in the corner throws
uppercuts Anderson again is attacking
Jake up against the ropes looks good
both guys look good this is an
entertainment fight if this is
entertainment this is exactly what you
was going to get your money for and I
absolutely love every last bit of it
maybe not be for everybody right
but these dudes are doing what they
doing
let me see Jay keep throwing jab like
he's telegraphing it yeah could be bait
sounds like it's working Jay can't move
his feet much but I ain't gonna count
them out yet this is a fact yeah I'm
team silver too
I'm team silver too can't lie
I got a bias going in
but at the same time
I respect you
that you Buck up on me boy don't [ __ ] up
on me
Jake come on man don't look this
deflated boy get up in there
Shake A Leg baby let's go
Anderson looks calm Jake looks like he
still have a ton of energy
Jake's breathing hard
this is round five
Anderson always been a master of control
especially of his breath
Jake tries to throw a right hand tries
to land a right hand he misses Anderson
miserably
Anderson throws that jab up and down
giving him levels
Jake throws a left hook right hand to
the body
Anderson covers up told Jake to come on
pretty good pretty good
Anderson catching the jab to the body
he's not moving Jake throws the right
hand Anderson catches it
and throws a jab Anderson now is in
Catching and pitching mode he's trying
to knock Jake out
Jake Winston grab Anderson is throwing
all the punches up through the middle
throws the right hand he throws a left
hook to Jake head he's trying to line
knock him out
this is the Integrity part that I talked
about people he has Jake up against the
ropes Jake is landing the shots but
Anderson is not affected Anderson is
trying to give up a cuts through the
middle Jake is trying to hold Anderson
is walking him down Jake is landing
right hands and left hooks on the side
of jig head he's stalking Jake he has
Jake in the corner Jake is trying to
land shots
Anderson is bringing all the punches up
through the middle looking like a young
Mike Tyson throwing these shots
uppercuts in the middle Jake is swinging
lights in the left hook but he misses
Anderson is stalking hands close walking
him in tight that's how you catch it
nice and close
Jake throws a right hand misses Anderson
goes right back to the body right back
to the body right and this Jake is
holding his arm Anderson is Swinging
with the other other arm
Anderson Bops on them still stalking
keeping his hands tight very tight
Anderson is
jab Jake does something he Jabs right to
the side of his head so Jake want to jab
Jake looks a little bit tired right now
and Anderson looks like he's watching
them seeing what he can do with his with
his prey what are you gonna do with his
food
round five Jake throws a right to the
body and a left hook misses both
pouring jab from Jake
but Anderson is on him
Anderson is walking them to the corner
and he wants to land that right hand he
lands it on the side of Jake's head in
the left hand
oh uppercut from Anderson Silva right
hand from Anderson Silva uppercut
Anderson Silva nine seconds left in the
round
right hand left hook right hand left
hook Anderson Silva is landing these
shots on Jake Paul pushing him off round
is over that round right there belongs
to the old man that old man put them
hands on that boy
Don't You Buck up on me boy
don't you do it that's what he done told
that's what I told him he done told him
that
he whispered in his hand said you know
you don't mess up now
you know you're messed up
gave round five to seven yo I got Jake
maybe about one round or so this is a
fun fight can't lie baby
experience of the fight is of despite is
too much yeah that 47 year old condition
is marvelous boy looking good out here
looking fresh looking delicious looked
like somebody had some Red Bull he gave
him Wings definitely that
yeah man
yeah man here we go we right back at it
again
Stuck in the Middle again
all right come on Jake let's see what
you got bar
Anderson keep tapping them with that jab
keep tapping them Jake fainting make
maybe Jake right now can get a second
win right
maybe get a second win there we go nice
right hand now that's the right hand
that I've seen him catching that there's
some silver with my mind's eye saw that
uh and I told Cog that shout out to [ __ ]
for watching
all right so Anderson
is leaning left and right in the center
of the Ring mixing his hands mixing them
mixing them
good stuff man good stuff that is that
muscle memory right
okay this is when you do it for real
he leaned in with a head bunt hit
Anderson with a head bump coming in
come on Jake
Jake trying to land that right hand
Anderson catching them with that South
Park jab that bang uh-huh Jake tried it
right there Anderson slipped both of
them that's when you in close you can
slip that see that slip that did them
legs like that show them legs like that
that old man legs look good boy
slide over on them here we go slide over
on them take like what the hell is going
on what did this dude take
Anderson through the jab right now they
both doing much of nothing Anderson is
on the Bop out dancing on the outside
Jake is watching let me Circle them
getting them dizzy
circling them like a snake get them
desert get them dizzy uh-huh Jake wanted
to throw that right hand but he thought
about it one two three catches Anderson
with that nice three Anderson said okay
one two three four and got going to his
body
right as long as you hold them ahead as
long as you hold I'm a hit I'll respect
that I respect it all
Anderson right back at it okay good job
good job
Anderson on his toes I'm talking about
marvelous conditioning boy
this guy can jog for days boy that's
some jogging on your behind
oh right hand left hook Anderson
Anderson
get him in the corner Anderson get him
in the corner Anderson body shot Jake
fighting off them ropes come on Jake
let's go up a cut in some left hook Jake
oh we that's what I'm talking about good
right hands from uh I mean Jabs from
Jake Jake jabbing his way out of there
jab Jake jab he trying to set him up
with that sleeper right here yeah
message me baby uppercut from Anderson
right hand from Anderson uppercut right
hand left hook right hand from Anderson
there we go left hook right hand from
Jake left hook from Jake up against him
oh my God these dudes is out here
banging I like that that's what I'm
talking about
this
is good this is good
tastes good
smells good looks good this is good
let's go how we gonna feel when they
give Jake the wind I don't care I would
say experience plays a huge Factor
apparently four to one actually good
Anderson cardio is crazy oh boy looking
good all this son look at this show this
dipping and slipping gotta respect that
dude I don't care what nobody see put
hands on you you put hands on that man
oh you saw him he hit him and said
like the Pillsbury Doughboy
Anderson get off on that round seven
this is looking good let's go
all right Anderson out there with that
jab uh-huh cutting distance with that
jab let's go in the center to the ring
gotta respect Jake Jake put a network in
that gym man go ahead boy go ahead boy
uh-huh right hand to the belly button
that's what you got to get them checked
to the belly button
belly button punch him in the stomach
Anderson don't care what he does
[Laughter]
you know what it is I think if you shave
Jay uh Jake's head ball it won't look
like he losing because his head get
moist it didn't look like he losing
pause
he got to stop that Spider-Man jab you
got to stop that look like he's shooting
web shooters cut it out man
gotta cut it out man stop that jab like
that
Anderson right there
good
good Anderson's stalking him come on
Anderson get him get him up against that
rope Jake went to dancing
with the dance oh left hook right hand
from Jake OH Anderson I look a little
puffy boy that jab must have been doing
something Anderson ah puffy
uh-huh
uh-huh
Anderson is stalking but he not Landing
though got a land when you stalk baby
Jake throwing that jab right hand oh
good right here from Jake that look good
kind of back Anderson up overhand right
Jake is trying it
uh-huh jab from Jake Jake looking good
this round Jake backing up but he's
Landing
he's Landing right hand from Anderson
here we go
here we go come on come on
good job from Jake Jake got that jab
pumping this whole fight
good Jake
right hand to the belly button
Anderson runs in with a one two three
Jake backs up
Anderson comes over the top grabs them
all right they step back
that 43 seconds good right in hand from
Jake
catches Anderson flush to the face
again Anderson is stalking catches Jake
catches him with a right hand Anderson
goes right to the body
brings it up through the middle
looking good looking good both of them
looking good entertainment folks this is
pure entertainment this is good
entertainment
getting your money's worth it's looking
good
nine seconds left in the round
good jab to the belly
oh Jake went for it Anderson went for it
landed his left
nice stuff
I do declare we got some nice stuff
I do declare
and this is stalking hard dude 50 left
it's only eight rounds 47 new 25 Am I
Wrong Jay got it back together Sylvia
might be slowing down fun fight dope
dope fight entertaining
do the Pillsbury Doughboy chuckle again
that one
here we go last round here we go
remember who's the a side who brought
the money to the table so don't be upset
if it goes the other guys why if it goes
to decision you see you just gotta buck
up and take that there baby
at the same time
we're looking for a knockout
round number eight
don't be late
somebody served up on a dinner plate
perhaps
Anderson is moving his hands rapidly
left hook right hand he's throwing all
types of shots
throwing right hands at Jake he's
turning his body he's hugging Got Jake
up against the ropes he throwing
everything at Jake Jake throwing left
hooks Anderson is going after him oh
Jake throws oh
Jake Paul drops
drops that happening folks oh my God
that's what happens when you open up you
might walk into something that's really
crispy that was a crispy shot a right
hand old man ain't said coming here we
go Jake is coming after him boy here it
is he said Don't You Buck up on me don't
you Buck up on me boy oh right hand over
the top Anderson legs don't look right
oh Jake Paul look like he's smelling
undefeated
and this is silver oh we baby you better
get that back and you better get it back
in blood
Anderson mad as hell
and it's so mad as hell his nose is
busted
[Laughter]
yo that's like when you snatch somebody
hat and they want to get it back
got your hat
oh man
Jake Anderson throws a right hand
catches Jake it don't matter right now
you better knock this boy down you
better knock him out you better do
something to him Jake going home with
this Jake keep Landing us over him right
Anderson might get knocked out
he caught Jake with a nice [ __ ]
let's go Anderson let's go Anderson
let's go Jason Memphis massage your arm
you see I got what I was looking for
thank you
shout out to Jake get what he was
looking for
um
[Laughter]
Anderson boy you better get him
hahaha
and that folks will conclude the evening
of fantastic fun 26 seconds
Jake
let's go
19 seconds
time passes by
ah 10 seconds and it's in the Wonder
Woman he tried he tried to look
there you go you open yourself up four
seconds left fight's over and we know
the winner
I don't care if you hate his guts I
don't care I don't care if you don't
like them
that boy put blood in your snow
you're going home man
got your hat
yo yo he's the ultimate gotcha hat guy
y'all thought it was gonna get to that
the eighth round
[Laughter]
yo he stopped when he when Anderson fell
everybody Collective Hearts Hit the
Floor too
gotta respect them
you don't gotta like them
he can pack a house
he gave Anderson Silva his biggest
payday
this kid is phenomenal
some special we watching
when it was all on the line when he was
looking done
boy caught him with that Bang
put him on a keister on a keister
dropped him
Anderson sat down like you couldn't
believe it like what the hell just
happened here where water
why am I looking at the rough knees
I didn't know that the ref was
bow-legged
hahaha
he said
how did I miss the fact that the ref was
bow-legged
[Laughter]
this is dope this is dope I care a lot
[Laughter]
of the frick boy
the pay-per-view numbers look will be
fantastic
it was a sellout crowd
pay-per-view numbers is gonna be dope
nah despite it slipped old knees yeah he
slipped into that punch
[Music]
he said oh God
[Laughter]
hit him with the oh God not now
I'm not like this this is it
I can see the memes now the internet is
gonna go but
he hit him with the oh God not like this
please
not in front of everyone
this is dope
yo
the
outcome
is is it's already determined sir it's
already determined so
I want to thank everybody for coming out
with the successful night
Jake
my hat's off to you
got your hat man
made a space for yourself sir
he took on
I noticed the Aging dude Sanderson Silva
I'm not getting out there fighting
Anderson Silva
um
respect
respect
it was good
very entertaining very good card very
good stuff respect I want to thank
everybody that showed up rocking out
with King
the professional fan
thank you each and every last one of
y'all
I'm glad that we could share these jokes
have fun
I want y'all to check this intro out
because this this this intro is the
outro
but it's banging
catch y'all tomorrow on IOP
1pm Eastern Standard Time
[Music]
being presented boxing afternoon
[Music]
into the combat talk haters in love with
a comeback salt if you really want it in
the rain God gonna send a contract off
knock his contacts out you will feel
mice trying to take a Viper ain't no
competition in the ring of Cipher cause
I'm spitting in my swinging fire talking
pickled peppers make them pay the piper
cause I might go live like a rude
discussion and deflate your chest like a
food reduction you be talking like you
want a new concussions and a dude a
custom attitude adjustment these are
fighting words better give me that
respect that I deserve for another
knuckle sandwich I would serve having
sipping moving like a tire swerve out
here acting bad thank you Michael
Jackson even got his winning only homie
Kevin you a phony homie now you owe me
action have them singing Tony Toni Toni
Braxton and they all wanna talk for
attention but the fame only lasts for an
instant mama got handsome and Bradford
attention imma leave them red you can
dance in Redemption
foreign
[Music]